So moin und seid ihr schon wach?
Na ja gut, was für eine Frage. Werde ja nicht immer aufwachen streben, wenn ihr schon wach
werdet. Was der Hals macht, ist es besser, aber was heißt, es ist anders. Also dieses
komische Inhalationsding, was ich da bekommen habe, bringt glaube ich nichts. Sackt. Wow,
warum ist der Subscription-Sound so laut? Luke Keats, du danke für den Sub. Sechs Monate
Hyper-Subscription, ja. Naja, es ist komisch, keine Ahnung. Es ist insgesamt, also man könnte
sagen, es ist ein bisschen besser, aber es ist anders. Es ist komisch, es ist merkwürdig.
Keine Ahnung. Ich hoffe, das geht demnächst alles wieder weg. Was hört man? Aber hören
tut man nur, weil ich noch nicht allzu lang wach bin. Kennst du das Graf? Was Graf? Cms?
Meinst du Crab? Oder heißt es wirklich Crab? Crab? Keine Ahnung, es sagt mir gar nichts.
Aber was heißt die? Flat File Cms. Ok, im Prinzip so was wie Doku Wiki dann oder was?
Er legt einfach Files hin und gut ist. Ja gut, heute machen wir was anderes.
Heute ist der übliche Sonntags-Morgens-Stell. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange ich on bin. Mal
gucken. Schon wegen Husten und so und allem. Hast du schon mal ein Proc-Video mit C-Sharp
gemacht? Vor ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz langer Zeit habe ich auf YouTube mal ein Video gemacht,
wo ich ein bisschen C-Sharp gezeigt habe für einen ganz anderen Anwendungszwerg, aber
das schon ewig her. Ja und ne, es ist anders jetzt einfach. Keine Ahnung. Vielleicht liegt
es aber auch an diesem Inhalierungszeug. Keine Ahnung. Mal schauen, mal schauen. Naja,
zumindest. Wir können mal eine Sache machen. Ja, richtig. Alter krass, du weißt das noch.
Ja, jaja, genau. Ich habe mal ein paar T-Shirts, ein paar Black Ops T-Shirts waren, also Black
Ops 1 T-Shirts verlost und die Ziehung habe ich mit einem Randomizer aus C-Sharp gemacht.
So 2009 oder 2007 oder irgendwann. Nee, warte mal, wann habe ich angefangen? YouTube 2010,
man wusste es direkt 2010 gewesen, das ist zu alt. So, ähm, warum habe ich hier eigentlich
Lidl offen? Ah, habe ich Lidl offen? Ah, wegen dieser komischen Zigbee Steckdosenleiste,
die ich nie gekauft habe. Ok, excellent, alles klar. Die Woche irgendwas spannendes passiert.
Console Ride feels Batman, ja. Ok, nichts IT-technisch großartiges. Bei der Gelegenheit,
wenn wir gerade dabei sind, Leute, wir gucken mal, wir gucken mal, warum habe ich nochmal
Ikea offen? Weil, ah, für den Schalter, ok, den wollte ich mir glaube ich auch mal holen
zum ausprobieren. Ja, es geht mir besser, aber, also nicht, besser kann man nicht sagen,
anders, anders. Es könnte aber auch sein, dass es an zwei Sachen liegt. Also vorher
habe ich ja relativ viel gehustet und alles und jetzt habe ich dieses Inhalationsding
vom Arzt gekriegt, was es auch sagt, ja. Also ich glaube nicht, dass es das wirklich besser
macht, aber ich habe jetzt die letzten Tage halt, weil es halt ultra langweilig war, mehr
Verbrechner gehauen als zu liegen und auch einmal gestreamt und gelabert mit euch und
so. Vielleicht ist es deswegen jetzt insgesamt nicht wirklich besser, aber allein schon,
dass es nicht schlechter ist und ich das machen kann, könnte heißen, es ist besser
insgesamt. Ach, keine Ahnung. Herzog zu Keller, Dankeschön für die drei Monate Subscription.
Was ist da? Ach, das ist das, ja, genau, das ist das Video von damals, das ist das Video
von damals. Da habe ich irgendeinen Randomizer zusammengeschmackt, Dezember 2010, Alter.
Ich schnarche kein, nein, also nicht, dass ich wüsste. So, ja, ja, das habe ich damals,
das habe ich damals gebastelt. Ja, das sind die Leute, die am Gewinnspiel teilgenommen
haben. Und dann habe ich aus, dann habe ich irgendwie gezogen, wer gewonnen hat. Jaja,
kann ich mich. Guckt mal, zu Zeiten, guckt mal, zu Zeiten, wo persönliche Messages gab.
Persönliche Nachrichten ist das ist das mittlerweile MSD, ist das mittlerweile DSGV oder gut, das
sind die Namen von den Leuten. Nee, das ist nicht Vista, das ist Windows 7. Das ist nicht
Vista, das ist Windows 7. Das dürfte so 2010, dürfte somit, wann kann Windows 7 raus? Windows
7 Release Date dürfte eines der ersten Windows, ja, guckt hier, das ist so eines der ersten
Windows 10 Ausgaben gewesen, die man hier sieht bei mir im Witz. Guckt mal, und der
gute alte Firefox, schaut euch mal an, guckt mal hier. Als Firefox noch wusste, wofür
man, guckt euch mal YouTube an, null. Als Firefox noch wusste, wofür sie ihren Browser machen.
Ja, so sieht es aus. So, YouTube, was empfiehlst du uns denn? Windows
7. Das ist mir eigentlich wurscht, was Microsoft da treibt. Zwei Booster, wann kommt die vierte
Eme? Es reicht ja irgendwie. Es ist ja auch immer gut, Alter. Ich hab mich erst vor zwei
Wochen boostern lassen. Geht das jetzt im Wochentakt oder was? Beruhigt euch, Alter.
Realschüler zu MW2-Zeiten. Oh ja, ich weiß, viele sind bei euch bei mir am Start, seit
sie in der Schule sind und jetzt sind sie irgendwie 25 oder so. Booster Any% Spiel.
Nein, es ist eher, es ist eher nicht Any%, es ist eher 100%. Wie bist du schon impferweiger?
Na klar, ich hab mich vor zwei Wochen impfen lassen. Das ist ja eindeutig das, was Impferweigerer
machen. Man verweigert die Impfung, indem man sich vor zwei Wochen impfen lässt. Close
für nächsten Monat 25. Ja, ist klar, ich weiß, es haben viele Leute zugeguckt, seit
sie in der Schule waren. Das heißt, sie sind wahrscheinlich so 14, 15, 16 gewesen und dementsprechend
ist es ganz jetzt zehn Jahre später. Eigentlich sogar schon zwölf Jahre später, fast elf
und halb Jahre später. Ja. Was verdient eine Unternehmensberaterin? Das hängt wahrscheinlich
ganz, jetzt gucken wir uns gleich mal an. Gucken wir uns nachher an. Wahrscheinlich,
das hängt ganz entscheidend davon ab, mit, das ist übrigens ein sehr gutes, sehr gutes
Meme für CSS, wie viel, wie viel Scheiße pro Sekunde sie reden kann. Weil, ich hab
das Gefühl, alle möglichen Consultants definieren sich eher auf Shit per second. Umso mehr
Shit per second abgesondert werden kann, umso mehr Geld. Du bist halt fast Anfang an
dabei und jetzt 28. Ja, kommt ja hin. Dann hast du angefangen so mit 16, 17 zu gucken
und jetzt ist es elf und halb Jahre her. Ist schon heftig, wenn man sich das überlegt.
Man muss sich echt mal überlegen. Die Leute haben bei mir als Kinder angefangen zu gucken,
Killerspiele auf YouTube sind heute teilweise immer noch am Start mit eigenen Kindern schon.
Also, sich mal vorstellen, was in elf und halb Jahren alles passieren kann. Gerade in
dieser Zeit von 15 so bis 25. Und ihr habt Killerspiele geguckt, genau. Und obwohl der
Pfeiffer euch gewarnt hat, obwohl der Pfeiffer gesagt hat, Killerspiele sind ganz furchtbar
schlimm. Mario XCB. Dankeschön. 13 Monate Subscription. Gunter Petersson. Interview C++.
Oh nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Kein C++. Server Rack Build. Wisst ihr, wie das aussieht?
Sieht nicht aus wie ein Server Rack, das sieht aus wie eine Kühlschranktür von vorne mit
den ganzen Aufdrucken. A Unified Dream Machine. Nee, nee, nee, hör mal bloß auf. Das kommt
nicht in mein Rack. Festplatte von eBay. Ich habe schreckliches gefunden. Okay, ich will
ich gar nicht wissen, was da drauf ist. Ganz ehrlich, die meisten Leute, denen ist ja überhaupt
nicht klar, dass sie ihren Kram vorher mal überschreiben sollten. Da findest du alles
mögliche. Von Dickpicks bis was auch immer. Oder auch anderes Zeug. Also, es gibt Sachen,
das muss ich anders erzählen. Also, früher habe ich mir jeden Scheiß, der irgendwie
aufgeploppt ist bei Suchergebnissen, bei YouTube Videos, überall auf allem möglichen. Ich
habe mir jeden Scheiß angeguckt, der in irgendeiner Art und Weise entfernt aufmerksamkeitsanziehend
gewirkt hat. Und ich habe so viel abartigen Scheiß geguckt aus Versehen dadurch, weil
ich das einfach gedacht habe, aha, okay, angeklickt und dann waren das die abartigsten Videos
aller Zeiten. Ich habe so viel ekligen Shit im Internet gesehen, das könnt ihr euch gar
nicht vorstellen. Und ich meine, wenn man jünger ist, sucht man ja nach manchem Schwachsinn
auch. Ich habe wirklich so viel ekliges Zeug und das Internet ist voll von abartigem, dreckigem,
ekligen Kack. Und irgendwann habe ich mir dann gesagt, Max, nur weil dir irgendjemand
einen Link schickt oder nur weil du irgendein Suchergebnis findest oder irgendwas, wo du
schon ahnen kannst, dass es eklig wird, machen wir einfach nicht mehr auf. Und so würde
ich das wahrscheinlich mit einer Festplatte machen, die ich irgendwo auf der Straße finde.
Ich wäre sehr geneigt dazu, die mal USB-technisch an irgendeinem Offline-Rechner oder so anzustöpseln
und mal drauf zu gucken oder in irgendeine Linux-VM oder so mal drauf zu gucken. Aber
sobald es auch nur Anzeichen ergibt davon, dass ich dort irgendwelche abartigen Dinger
von fremden Leuten sehe, ich würde es einfach abziehen und gut ist. Ich habe so viel ekligen
Scheiß mittlerweile im Internet schon gesehen. Ich muss mir nicht wissentlich noch mehr
ekligen Scheiß angucken. Okay, was hat er denn gefunden? Hey, das ist mein Zahnarzt!
Das ist der Typ, der klingt wie mein Zahnarzt oder? Sekunde, Sekunde. Ja, das ist der Typ,
der klingt wie mein Zahnarzt, genau. Ich erinnere mich. Ich erinnere mich, von dem haben wir
schon mal ein Video geguckt. Ich glaube, von dem habe ich sogar noch ein Video offen, weil
es mir empfohlen wurde. Ja, der klingt wie mein Zahnarzt.
How games get miniguns wrong? Illegal. Illegal Lego Technik. Wer soll das illegal sein? Kommen
dann die Lego Anwälte und sagt, ne, wenn du so deine Bricks zusammenklemmst, dann ist
das illegal, oder wie? Lego verklagt mich, ja. Okay, ich habe übrigens die Sachen im
falschen Fenster aufgemacht, weil hier ist ja eigentlich der Musik-Tab. Jetzt muss ich
rüber kopieren. Kann man das so? Moment, das habe ich noch nie ausprobiert, Leute. Boah,
das geht! Wusstet ihr, dass das geht? Wusstet ihr, dass ihr mehrere Tabs verschieben kann?
Also drei Tabs auf einmal, track und dropen, wusstet ihr, dass das geht? Das war mir bis
jetzt nicht klar, dass das funktioniert. Ja, der Chat wusste es natürlich. Der Chat weiß
sowas immer. Immer. Immer, wenn ich frage, wo ist denn das? Ja, Max, das wusste ich schon
lange. Das weiß ich schon seit 15 Jahren. Das ist überhaupt nichts Neues. Ich habe
es am besten sind dann noch die Leute, die sagen, ich habe es selbst programmiert so
nach dem Motto. Ja, ich war bei der Entwicklung dabei. Ich war Teamleiter des Teams, was dieses
Feature implementiert hat. Ich habe es committed, genau. Wie hast du die drei markiert mit
Shift? Shift kannst du mehrere Tabs markieren. So, was gucken wir uns jetzt an? Was gucken
wir uns jetzt an? A Battlefield New Map Details Datamined. Na dann, wir lassen uns G-Baiten
von Level Cap. Level Cap G-Bait ist angesagt. New Map Info, oh, also die Map, die wir im
Sommer bekommen, also eine Map und so. Geil. By the way, das ist Modern Warfare, oder? Ja,
das habe ich auch gehört, dass nächstes Jahr kein Call of Duty kommen soll. Aber da muss
man mal ehrlich sagen, wie beschissen die letzten Teile auch so performt haben. Also
ich meine nicht Performance auf dem PC, sondern Vanguard hat es überhaupt nicht gut verkauft
und was war davor, das letzte Black Ops? Das war glaube ich auch nicht so wahnsinnig
geil. Egal, schauen wir mal. Schauen wir mal, lassen wir uns ein Level Cap G-Baiten. Stopp.
Stopp. Stopp. Wir haben eine ganz klassische Sache vergessen, die wir jeden Stream machen.
Stopp. Wir müssen Spielerzahlen von New World gucken. Es wird okay, es wird immer schlechter.
Aber immerhin, sie haben 34.000 Leute von einer Million. So und wir müssen Battlefield-Spielerzahlen
gucken. Perfekt. Ach, Service. Service-Game. Darf ich euch mal was fragen? Wie Lost Ark? Gut,
Lost Ark gucken. Das ist eine gute Idee. Lost Ark gucken wir mal. Ich habe eine Frage an euch.
Battlefield 2042 ist doch ein Service-Game. Wo ist denn der Service in Battlefield 2042?
Der Refund Service. Also ich meine, das Game hat seit Release nichts bekommen. Wo ist das Service?
Lost Ark. Gut. Lost Ark droppt von 1,2 Millionen jetzt runter hier auf 868.000 MMO Release. Bin ich
mal gespannt. Gucken wir uns mal an in ein paar Wochen. Bin ich gespannt, wie das verläuft. Also
ich habe selbst Lost Ark nicht gespielt. Ich glaube, ich habe auch keine Zeit für noch weiteren MMO
Kreiselgrind. Aber ich habe mit ein paar Leuten gechattet, die das auch versucht haben zu spielen.
Sie meinen, es ist wohl ein äußerst anstrengender Kreiselgrind, das Endgame. Elden Ring. Gibt es
noch keine Stats für? Es ist doch erst seit zwei Tagen raus. Ich glaube, da haben die noch keine
kleine Stats für gesüngt. Was hat es eigentlich mit diesem Game auf sich? Das habe ich auf Twitch
schon ein paar Mal gesehen. Das ist irgendwie so ein, keine Ahnung, Weep, MMO oder sowas. Das
spielen total viele. Was soll ich anfangen? Elden Ring oder Lost Ark? Ich glaube, Unterschiede hier könnten
Spiele ja kaum sein. Das eine ist ein MMO, das andere ist ein Singleplayer Game und das eine ist
Top Down, das andere ist Third Person, das andere ist eher Dark Souls, das andere ist eher Diablo
Style-mäßig. Kann man es schlecht mit anderen vergleichen. Rob Records. Cyberpunk, lass mal kurz
gucken. Cyberpunk hat mehr Spieler als Battlefield? Echt, wirklich? Das ist Singleplayer Game, das hat
mehr Spieler als Battlefield. Cyberpunk hat mehr Spieler als Battlefield. Das verstehe ich nicht.
Corona am Start hier. Ich sollte doch noch mal wieder einen Corona-Test machen. Ich habe zwar
welche gemacht, aber... Jetzt soll ich noch mal einen machen. Also, was haben wir denn sonst noch zu
bieten? Wir gucken uns jetzt an. Wir lassen LevelCapture baiten. Selbst Euro Truck Simulator hat mehr.
Der Landwirtschaftssimulator, Leute. Wie heißt denn der Landwirtschaftssimulator? Farming Simulator?
Kann das sein? Ja. Sogar der Landwirtschaftssimulator hat zehnmal mehr... Was heißt zehnmal? Fünfzehnmal
mehr Spieler als Battlefield. Der fucking Landwirtschaftssimulator. Und es kam ungefähr
zur ähnlichen Zeit raus. Übrigens, Farming Simulator. Da kann ich mich an eine Sache erinnern.
Der Farming Simulator stand auf der Gamescom, auf der letzten Gamescom, wo ich gewesen bin. Das ist
auch schon ein paar Jahre her. Das war dann der Farming Simulator 2017 oder sowas. Der war sehr
beliebt, der Stand. Wisst ihr warum? Ratet mal. Da kommt ihr nie drauf. Farming Grills, das ist
schon nicht verkehrt. Ja, das ist nicht verkehrt. Also, der Farming Simulator war so beliebt,
weil die hatten dort einen Traktor stehen und sie hatten zwei leicht bekleidete Traktorgrills davor
stehen und du konntest dich dann mit denen, die haben sich dann auch auf den Traktor drauf gelegt
und sowas teilweise, du konntest dich quasi mit auf dem Traktor liegenden Mädels fotografieren
lassen. Das war der Renner. Da war immer was los. Da hätte RTL jetzt gefragt, die Gamer auf der
Gamescom und hast du schon ein Mädchen heute angesprochen? Kann sich noch jemand an diesen
RTL Bericht erinnern? Ich habe kein Bild gemacht, es gibt kein Bild mit mir. Aber das war ein sehr
beliebter Stand. Der Stand war mini damals. Heute haben die wahrscheinlich viel viel mehr Geld und
viel mehr Fans. Der Stand war wirklich klein. Das war einfach so ein kleiner quadratischer Stand.
Das Einzige, was da stand, hinten war ein Schild, Farming Simulator, Landwirtschaftssimulator und
davor war ein Traktor mit zwei Mädels. Was ich jetzt nicht weiß, ist, ob die Mädels gewechselt
haben, weil ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie da irgendwie eine Woche lang quasi zwölf
Stunden oder so die gleichen zwei stehen hatten. Das war wahrscheinlich von irgendeinem Messe,
Mädels Service, wo du dir welche mieten kannst und die haben halt gewechselt, die dabei standen.
Zumindest, du konntest dich dort mit Mädels auf dem Traktor fotografieren lassen. Das war der Renner
auf der Gamescom. Seitdem ist der Farming Simulator bei mir insofern auch unten durch,
dass ich mir das Game nie wieder angeguckt habe. Ich habe mir immer gedacht, das Game interessiert
mich an sich nicht. Der Stand hat mich jetzt auch nicht wirklich vom Game überzeugt. Seitdem geht
mir das voll sonst wo vorbei. Obwohl es ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das wisst, es gibt Farming
Simulator eSport. Passt mal auf. Es gibt Farming Simulator eSport. Wer fährt am schnellsten den
Baumstamm in die Scheune und sowas? Passt mal auf. Das müsst ihr euch mal angucken. Da keckt er euch
weg. Farming Simulator eSport. Es gibt Farming Simulator eSport.
Insane. Ich meine, das könnte auch ein Zusammenschnitt sein von irgendeinem anderen
Game. Farming Simulator, was ist das Competition? Ohne 360-Hertzmonitoren geht da nichts.
Landtechnik Oberfalz ist am Start. Egal, wir haben jetzt genug geguckt.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass MyInsanity eine Landwirtschaftssimulator-Team hat.
Das war scheiße, oder? Das habt ihr jetzt auch mal gesehen. Landwirtschaftssimulator eSport.
So. Alter, was war das Ding, Leute?
Okay, wir lassen uns jetzt aber endgültig mal Level-Capture baiten. Das ist ja schon die ganze
Zeit, was ich machen will. Auf, zeig dir. Noch höhere.
Hat er uns gerade ernsthaft erzählt, irgendjemand auf Twitter hat eine neue High-Resolution von
dem Leak gepostet und er plennt uns noch nicht mal ein? Geil. Top.
Übrigens, habe ich euch erzählt, dass NordVPN bei mir Werbung machen will.
Und dann habe ich halt geantwortet, warum nicht? Kann ich mir vorstellen, stellt ihr Material zur
Verfügung? Oder wie machen wir das? Ich habe ja mittlerweile einen Manager, der sich um sowas
kümmert. Und waren wir uns eigentlich einig? Und danach haben sie gesagt, Moment, es gibt da
ein Problem mit dem Channel. Und haben dieses Video hier verlinkt. Kein Witz, Leute. Und dieses
Video haben verlinkt und haben gemeint, hm, ich glaube, der Marketing Typ hat dann geschrieben,
I don't believe NordVPN will be happy represented by this channel. Irgendwie sowas. Wobei,
nee, der hat das sogar auf Deutsch geschrieben. NordVPN will das nicht, weil Zeugs, weil VPN
kritische Videos auf dem Channel. Und jetzt mache ich wohl kein NordVPN. Also die Sache,
ich hatte zur Auswahl, ich lösche das Video und mache das Placement oder ich mache das
Placement nicht. So ich werde definitiv kein Video löschen, habe ich noch nicht mal für
irgendwelche damals Exclusive Call of Duty Dinger gemacht. Ich lösche prinzipiell keine
Videos, nur weil irgendjemand sagt, es gefällt ihnen nicht. Also das Video habe ich nicht
gelöscht, ich habe ihnen angeboten, ich kann das thematisieren, ich kann sagen, ich habe
ein Video dazu gemacht. Es gibt aber durchaus die einen oder anderen Punkte, wo es sinnvoll
sein kann, einen VPN zu verwenden. Aber wollen sie anscheinend nicht. Da habe ich mir gedacht,
dann halt nicht. Das ist jetzt nicht so, als wäre ich wahnsinnig darauf angewiesen, dass
NordVPN da was macht bei mir. Habe ich erzählt, dass NordVPN mein Passwort verloren hat und
ich dann von irgendeinem random eine Mail mit mache. Das wäre aber sehr unvorteilhaft
für NordVPN sollte das stimmen. Der Raid Shadow Legends, die haben auch irgendwelche
komischen Verträge, also das ist alles Müll. Auf Fivehead, das müsste man machen. Egal,
wir lassen uns jetzt endgültig mal Levelcap schieben, wird mal langsam Zeit. Fertig gucken.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Hier. Ach nee, das war Placement. Sind wir noch nicht fertig?
Wie lang ist das Placement? Ich brauche Sponsor Block. Was schon was über die neue IP Rotation
Funktion von Surfshark gehört. War Surfshark nicht dieser mp3 Dienst von Microsoft, der
dann, was das Video ist zu laut. Was war das denn Microsoft, Microsoft mp3, irgendwas mit
Shark war das doch. Das hieß doch irgendwas mit Shark. Groove Shark war das, oder? Aber
das war gar nicht Microsoft. Oder doch? Okay, keine Ahnung, da bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander.
Groove Shark war das, wo man damals kostenlos Musik hören konnte mit Werbung dazwischen
und sowas. Das war eigentlich so eines der Vorreiter in dieser Richtung, haben es aber
nie großartig gehabt. Was, das Video ist zu laut? Wirklich? Das passt doch ganz gut.
Das Video ist tatsächlich so. So, jetzt sind wir ungefähr gleich laut. Und wenn ist das
immer noch Placement? Ist das immer noch Placement? Der ist aber. Okay, Sekunde, Sekunde. Nein,
nein, ich mache keinen Sponsor Block hier on stream, weil letztendlich wir gucken Videos
von anderen Leuten, die haben es auch verdient, dass wir manchmal nicht alles skippen an Placements.
Jetzt kriegen wir Bilder von gezeigt. Okay. New Level. Es ist groß, es ist flach und
es ist leer. Das scheint eine Battlefield 2042 Map zu sein. Was ist das da? Da ist einfach
so eine Ecke am Berg. Natürlich ist das flach. Guck mal hier. Und hier. Das ist alles. Weil
nur weil hier mal eine Klippe ist, ist der Rest flach. Aber hier findet ja kein Gameplay
statt so vertikal an der Klippe. Du rennst entweder da unten, du rennst hier, das ist
wahrscheinlich spielst du hier gar nicht, sondern spielst hier. Ach, was auch immer.
Es ist so fehl, es ist so fehl. Das Game ist so dead, das Game ist einfach nur dead.
Natürlich. Wo soll er sonst auch herkommen? Die gleichen unfähigen Leute, die die Originalmaps
gemacht haben, machen jetzt neue Maps. Warum sollten die auf einmal fähiger sein?
Ganz ehrlich, die könnten einfach, also wenn sie wirklich das Game auf einen Schlag verbessern
wollten, einfach alte Maps importieren von allen Battlefields und die neuen rausschmeißen.
Oder, oder, vielleicht ein paar Bereiche aus den neuen Maps nehmen und daraus fielen sich
Spielerkarten, was auch immer. Im Prinzip das, was ich in meinem Video gesagt habe,
was man machen müsste, wenn ich da als Chef wäre. Fertig.
One, both maps offer engaging infantry only areas while also leaving space for vehicle
players. Now the new skins found by Temporial have been more well received by players compared
to Christmas. Das ist mir noch gar nicht aufgefallen, dass es so eine Elfenmütze gab für Angel.
Yeah, Angel does it again. Miss boar skins that was leaked at the end of last year, which
saw a massive backlash. By contrast, many fans are actually in favor of these additions
like the weapon camos. Könnt ihr euch noch erinnern an das Epic Headgear, was es jetzt
gibt für Angel in Battlefield? Es gibt eine Mütze. Stell euch mal vor, eine Mütze. Jetzt
aber vorbei. Einfach eine normale Mütze, Epic Headgear. Sogar die Playerkarte sieht
billig aus. Das bedeutet, das bedeutet, sie labern nächste Woche mal wieder was in irgendeinem
Blogpost. Nicht, dass ich was tue oder so. Okay, Chat. Chat. Was? Was? Was? Moment Sekunde.
Was ist mit Battlefield? Lustige Geschichte. Hat mein PC neu entzählt und musste alle Origin
Games neu entzählen, weil der Origin Launcher zu dumm ist. Bereits vorhandene Spiele auf
der HDD zu erkennen. Windows halt auf SSD mit HDD. Habe alle Spiele installiert, aber Battlefield
war schon nicht wieder installiert. Ja, hast du recht. Habe ich das noch installiert? Nee,
ich hab schon runtergeschmissen, ne? Ja, ja. Ist weg. Also ich persönlich tippe ja drauf,
dass es zu dem größeren Update im Sommer soweit ist. Wenn überhaupt. Danach macht es eigentlich
keinen Sinn mehr. Wahrscheinlich ist Battlefield free to play. Mobile sogar noch das bessere
Game versus Battlefield 42. Nur, dass ich garantiert nicht auf einem Handheld, äh nicht
auf dem Handel, auf einem Tablet und auf einem Telefon spielen werde mit Touchscreen. Vielleicht
kann man dann, kann man cheaten auf Android wieder mit einem Controller oder Maus oder
so. Wie es ja bei manchen anderen Games ging. Die haben uns so cheap baited mit diesem Trailer,
Leute. Das ist krass. Der Trailer war so gut, das Spiel so scheiße. Und sie haben im Trailer
gezeigt, dass es überhaupt nicht gibt. Naja. Ich meine, es ist nun mal ein Spiel, wo es
halt auch Russland als Fraktion gibt. Also, okay. Naja, okay. Die wollen halt einfach
irgendwelchen, irgendwelchen, irgendwie, wie soll ich sagen, wie gearteten auch immer
gedingsten Shitstorms aus dem Weg gehen. Will man wirklich mit denen zusammenarbeiten?
Nee, die wollen ja, dass ich mein Video lösche. Ah, nice, nice. Okay, so, nice. Super. Äh,
wobei ich mir da Gedanken machen würde, dass es vielleicht sogar ein Fishing Attempt ist
oder so. Keine Ahnung, wer, wer das sein soll. Naja.
Prime Cosmetics? Was hat denn Prime jetzt damit zu tun? Über Twitch oder was? Twitch,
äh, Unlocks oder was? Oder was? Was hat Prime jetzt auf einmal mit Battlefield zu tun? Ach,
Twitch Prime. Ich mach' mich mal ganz im Ernst. Sogar die Skins sehen scheiße aus. Das ist
so billig alles. Das ist irgendwie sowas. Wisst ihr, das ist nichts, was man extra irgendwie
veröffentlicht. Das ist im Season Pass Level 1 bis 100 ist das Level 35 oder so. Was du
mal kurz so einfach überspringst, da ist es halt mit drinne. Next, next, next, next. Das
ist nichts, wo du sogar noch ein extra Bild von machst. Gibt es wirklich irgendjemand,
der dafür sein Amazon-Account linked? Das ist der Hacker-Man mit ein paar Purple-Streifen
drauf. Sieht es ehrlich gesagt aus, als sind nicht das Streifen, es sieht so aus, als ist
das Ding aufgeplatzt und er ist lila unten drunter. Was durchaus sein kann, weil er unten
drunter keine Texturen hat. Ich meine, es ist immer Battlefield 2042. Hier erkenne ich
noch nicht mal, dass es überhaupt ein Skin ist. Ach doch, hier vorne. Ach, ach ja.
Ja, das habe ich auch schon gelesen. Wie gesagt, die letzten zwei kamen auch nicht gut an.
Das habe ich mich damals schon gefragt bei diesem Trailer. Also, warum springt die auf
die Motorhaube, um dann in das Fenster rein zu schießen? Warum schießt sie nicht einfach
von vorne auf das Fenster? Wozu muss man auf die Motorhaube springen? Außer, dass es
vielleicht für diesen Shot gut aussieht.
Ich zeige auch immer Dominanz in Frankfurt dadurch, dass ich bei den anderen Leuten
auf die Motorhaube steige. So macht man das halt. Übrigens Leute, weil ihr das letzte
Mal im Stream nicht dabei wart, wo wir gerade dabei sind, letztens bei uns, bei mir hier
um die Ecke. Riesenpolizei-Einsatz. Wirklich, 50 Polizisten oder so am Hanauer Hauptbahnhof.
Riesending. 20 Streifenwagen. Das SEK war am Start. Und wisst ihr warum? Ich habe es
im letzten Schreiben schon erzählt, aber da waren nicht so viele Leute da. Und zumindest
nicht die gleichen. Wisst ihr wann? Hanau, Axt. Nicht Akt, Axt. Linienbus mit Axt bestiegen.
Dann in Psychiatrie eingewiesen. Irgendein Typ ist mit der Axt in ein Bus und hat dann
dort rumgeschrien. Und dann haben die Leute die Polizei gerufen und als der Bus am Hauptbahnhof
angehalten hat, wurde es umstellt von der Polizei. Da war richtig was los. Richtig. Wie gesagt,
ich habe noch nie einen SEK-Einsatz. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es in Hanau überhaupt möglich
ist, dass da ein SEK anrückt. Aber anscheinend ist das tatsächlich so. Der Mann, der am
Mittwoch mit einer Axt einen Linienbus in Hanau bestiegen hat, befindet sich nun in
der Psychiatrie. Ja gut, wenn du mit einer Axt in einem Linienbus bist, rumschreist und
irgendwie im Zweifelsfall noch droht, Leute anzu-Axten, dann hast du wahrscheinlich auch
rechtlich verdient, in die Psychiatrie zu kommen. Was, er sei einschlägig polizeibekannt
und zum Zeitpunkt in einem psychischen Ausnahmezustand gewesen. Naja, zum Glück ist keinem was passiert.
Zum Glück ist keinem was passiert. Egal, gucken wir jetzt fertig. Da war was los hier
in Hanau, sage ich euch. Also, das kommt hier nicht so oft vor. Warum ist er mit dem Axt-Typ
eigentlich weitergefahren? Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass Busfahrer in gewisser Weise einen
Security-Protokoll haben. Nach dem Motto, mach nichts, was den Typ weiter aufstachelt.
Und wenn jemand in den Bus einsteigt und du sagst, ich fahre nicht weiter, bis sie aussteigen,
dann wird er vielleicht aggressiv. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es dort bestimmt
irgendwelche Security-Guidelines gibt, wie man sich im Fall eines, wie auch immer, Gartenangriffes
verhalten soll. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass entweder, das steht da leider nicht, also
ich gehe davon aus, dass entweder die Leute bei der Polizei angehufen haben, im Handy
aus dem Bus oder der Busfahrer einen Knopf hatte für Alarm. Wahrscheinlich beides. Also,
es ist eh interessant, wie gut die Polizei mittlerweile Bescheid weiß über alles, was
so in der Stadt passiert. Ich habe nur einmal die Polizei in Frankfurt kontaktiert. Also
einmal musste ich zur Polizei, zur Polizei Station 4 oder so ist das glaube ich in Frankfurt,
das ist am Hauptbahnhof vorbei oder links rum. Zumindest musste ich dorthin, weil mein Chef
wurde überfallen. Ich meine, wir reden von Frankfurt. Mein Chef wurde überfallen abends
am Bahnhof und ihm wurde seine Geldbörse abgenommen. Und die haben dann die Typen
geschnappt ein paar Tage später und ich sollte zur Polizei gehen für meinen Chef und sollte
das abholen, so während der Arbeitszeit. Also das war noch, als ich Azubi war. Das ist
schon ein bisschen her. So, ich habe ansonsten nur einmal von mir aus die Polizei kontaktiert
in Frankfurt und das war, als einer auf der Brücke gestanden hat und runterspringen wollte.
Da bin ich von der Arbeit heimgelaufen zum Südbahnhof, aber ich kann euch das mal kurz,
ups, das hat mit Franzosen nichts zu tun. Maps, Frankfurt, ich zeige euch das mal kurz,
wo das Skill ist in Frankfurt. Frankfurt, Billy Brandplatz, hier, hier unter mein Brücke.
Hier bin ich lang gelaufen, also ich laufe immer runter zum Südbahnhof, der Südbahnhof
ist hier unten irgendwo da. Dann bin ich hier lang gelaufen und hier, so ziemlich auf der
Mitte der Brücke, stand so ein Dude drauf und wollte von der Brücke springen. Und da
habe ich die Polizei kontaktiert. Ich habe auf Twitter geschrieben. Twitter, add Polizei
Frankfurt. Und dann hat die Polizei Frankfurt geantwortet, irgendwie danke für den Hinweis,
sie wissen schon Bescheid, sie sind unterwegs. Wie hoch ist das? Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube
nicht hoch genug, dass man davon stirbt. Außer man kann nicht schwimmen. Ich habe den auf
Twitter geschrieben, ja. Klar, Twitter anstatt anrufen, warum nicht? Hauptsache, Hauptsache
du kontaktierst sie. Ich glaube nicht, dass es hoch genug ist, dass man davon stirbt.
Ich wollte da wirklich nicht anrufen, ich habe mir gedacht, warum soll sie nicht über
Twitter schreiben? Ist doch egal. Hauptsache, sie wissen Bescheid. Sie wissen schon und
sind auf dem Weg. Und es kam dann auch hier um die Ecke, keine Ahnung, 2-3 Minuten später
kam Krankenwagen und die Polizei um die Ecke geflitzt. Ja, dann bin ich weiter zum Südbahnhof.
Das ist das einzige, wo ich die Polizei in Frankfurt kontaktiert habe bisher. Twitter
dauert nicht länger, die haben permanent einen bei Twitter sitzen, von der Polizei
in Frankfurt. Also wenn ich jetzt irgendwo bei einem Banküberfall dabei wäre, dann
würde ich auch anrufen. Ja Moment, was heißt Ripple Effects of the Industry? Es hat so
gut wie keiner mehr außer Call of Duty in diesem Bereich einen Yearly Release Cycle.
Call of Duty ist so das letzte, was jährlich neue Sachen rausbringt. Und so die Trendsetter
in dieser Richtung, was Fortnite angeht und Apex und sonst was, jetzt haben sie auch Warzone
am Start, die haben doch nie jährlich released. Der einzige Krempel, der jährlich rauskommt,
ist Call of Duty oder aber irgendwelche EA Sports Shit. Ich weiß nicht, selbst Need
for Speed kommt doch glaube ich nicht mehr jährlich raus, oder? Ja ach, was? Was? Was
kommen wir denn dahin? Releasen wenn man ready ist? Jetzt hätten sie mal Dice erzählen
sollen vielleicht. Ne ne, also ich glaube, releasen wenn man ready ist, das können wir
uns abschminken. Das ist in der Gaming Industrie 2022 nicht mehr so. Vielleicht bei irgendwelchen
Indie-Spielen, aber nicht bei irgendwelchen super mega teuren Triple-A-Hasse-sonst-nichts-gesehen-Spielen.
Übrigens, eine Sache, die ich schon vermutet habe, ist jetzt auch eingetreten und zwar
der Uncharted-Film ist scheiße. Dachte ich mir ja schon, aber nachdem ich mir jetzt ein
paar Reviews angeguckt habe, habe ich mir das nicht nur gedacht, sondern er ist auch
wirklich scheiße. Anyway, oh no, anyway, genau, das war eigentlich davon auszugehen, spätestens,
seitdem sie sogar die Story geändert haben, weil sie sich gedacht haben, fuck drauf was
die Spieler erzählt haben und warum Sully keinen Bart hat, naja, was auch immer. Die Typen
sehen eh überhaupt nicht aus, ich will da voll nicht anfangen. Was hat der Typ eigentlich
mit seinem Arm hier getrieben?
Sony shared a first look at their new PSVR headset, which features major hardware improvements
and a much slimmer, lighter design. This second generation headset features a new vent to disperse
heat generation, which also stops the lens from fogging up while gaming. Sony outlined
that they have paid close attention to the ergonomics of the headset to ensure it's
comfortable to wear over very long periods of time. The original PSVR revolutionized
VR headset designed by incorporating a rigid weight distribution instead of the typical
...
Ich glaube, ohne Scheiß, ich glaube, das am längsten gespielte VR Spiel ist immer
noch VR Chat, oder? Wobei das ja weniger ein Spiel ist, sondern eher ein Chatraum mit
bisschen Zeug. Ich meine, VR Chat ist eigentlich seit Jahren jetzt schon halbwegs beliebt.
Ja, es gibt mittlerweile doch ganz gute VR Spiele, ja, aber es ist doch schon sehr
wenig. Ist es nicht viel? Ich meine, Half-Life hast du, dann hast du irgendeinen Resident
Evil Teil, der wohl ganz gut gewesen sein soll. Also ich rede jetzt von richtig großen Titeln,
ja. So viel gibt's da gar nicht. Außer die Leute, die halt permanent in VR Chat abhängen.
...elastic bands, most headsets at the time used. So Sony definitely knows what they're
doing when it comes to comfort. In terms of specs, the PSVR2 boasts an improved 4K HDR
OLED display over the last gen's 1080p screen. The frame rates offered with the new model
are also much improved. It'll be able to refresh at both 90 and 120 Hz, which will
result in a much more fluid gaming experience. The PSVR2 headset is expected to release later
this year, provided that the worldwide chip shortage has been remedied to some degree.
PlayStation's Game Pass competitor, codenamed Project Spartacus, is also expected to be
detailed very soon. In December of last year, Bloomberg reported that Sony was working on
their own version of the Xbox Game Pass with a launch target date of next spring.
Elden Ring, the highly anticipated skill-based action RPG, has finally launched and is already
receiving massive ratings from fans and critics, with flawless scores across the board, making
it the highest rated title of all time on Open Critic. Its day one stats are simply
...
Ja, das muss ich mal ein bisschen setzen. Das ist das komplette Gegenteil in dem Fall
von Battlefield 2042. Battlefield 2042 hat mega enttäuscht und die Fans waren ultra
gepisst und haben es quasi noch schlechter bewertet, als es eigentlich hätte bewertet
werden müssen. Und da ist es jetzt so, das Spiel ist richtig gut und ist sogar noch besser
als man gedacht hat, aber die Fanboys, die flippen jetzt total aus. Also ich denke mal,
kein Game hat, wie soll ich sagen, nichts ist fehlerfrei. Ich denke mal, das muss ich
jetzt auch mal erst so 2-3 Monate setzen, bis man dann was realistisches liest, aber
überall durch die Bank weg, muss man echt sagen, kommt das mega gut weg.
Außer genau, außer dass die PC Version wohl nicht gut läuft.
Ja, 60 FPS mit Physik an FPS gelockt ist natürlich doof, aber es ist denke ich erträglich,
ich finde es doof, dass es so ist. Aber ich finde es insofern erträglich, wenn es dann
auch wirklich konstante FPS sind. Also wenn das dann auch immer 60 FPS hat. Weil 60 FPS
und dann noch Drops ist doof. Aber wenn du permanent konstante 60 FPS hast und das Spiel
ist ja auch relativ langsam, das ist jetzt ja irgendwie kein Mirrors Edge oder so, wo
du rumjumpst wie verrückt, das ist bestimmt spielbar mit 60 FPS.
Aber ja. Memory Leaks. Das gehört ja zum guten Ton, dass irgendwie so was mittlerweile
in einem Spiel drin ist. Kann ja nicht sein, dass es einfach funktioniert ist. Wo kommen
wir denn dahin?
Ok.
Die Arbeit an einem Patch, um diese Probleme zu beantworten, ist bereits unterwegs, aber bis es zu Ende ist,
empfehlen die Entwickler, das Spiel regelmäßig zu rebooten, um die Datenverlust zu verhindern.
Looter Shooter und Moon Wizard MMO Destiny 2s lange erwartete Witch Queen-Expansion
wurden diese Woche geübt und wurden gut von Fans erzielt.
Obwohl es nicht gut ging für die PlayStation 4-Spieler, die sehr lange warten mussten.
Schließlich konnten die Spieler die Content vorher nicht preloaden.
Live, das entstand in langer Zeit, um sogar die 72GB-Update zu downloaden.
Dennoch haben sich viele Fans die Expansions-Narrative, Direktion und wunderschöne Ausführungen geprägt.
Valve hat sich für ihre Discount-Polizei geändert.
Am 28. März werden die Discount-Cool-Down-Periode und Discount-Nahme verwendet.
Die Entwickler und Publisher werden nicht mehr ihre Produkte von mehr als 90% oder weniger als 10% verkaufen können.
Auf der Fläche sieht das nicht aus wie eine konsumentfreundliche Entscheidung.
Aber wenn man weiter geht, kann diese Veränderung zwei wichtigen Bereiche verbessern.
Das wird die Publisher nicht mehr abwürgen, wenn sie ein Spiel verkaufen können.
Auch wenn der Verkaufspreis nur etwas weniger ist als der Verkaufspreis.
Also kannst du quasi sagen, ich hab jetzt ein Game rausgebracht für 50€ und ich mach's on sale für 49,50€ und dann promoted Steam das Game.
Feifett!
Easy!
Solange es nicht wow wird!
Ob diese Veränderung tatsächlich verbessert wird, bleibt zu sehen.
Wir werden sehen, wann das Update im lateinigen März aussteigen wird.
Die Steam Next Fest ist auch diese Woche unterwegs,
die Spotlight auf hunderts von freien Demonstrationen und Developer-Livestreams.
Mit so vielen Spielen auf der Suche gibt es hier ein paar, die du probieren kannst, bevor das Event morgen endet.
Boundary, ein neuer Taktik-FPS, wo du die Rolle von Astro-Operatoren in zerstörenden 0G-Batteln in der Wälderung des Spaces erlaubst.
Du kannst es hier auf meinem Kanal sehen, in der Videobeschreibung unten verlinkt.
Und Ixion, ein neuer Sci-Fi-City-Bilder der Warhammer-40k-Developer in Bulwark.
Die Spieler werden ihre eigenen Stadt bauen können.
Gehen Sie auf einen Quest, fangen Sie auf die Ressourcen und besuchen das massive Spielgebiet.
Bevor wir heute's letzte Thema besuchen, würden wir gerne hören, was Sie sagen müssen über Battlefield 3.
... und was Sie von der neuen Exposure-Map sehen möchten.
Hoffen Sie, dass es ein 1-1-Remake von Battlefield 3s Damavon Peak ist oder würden Sie etwas komplett Neues preferieren?
Lassen Sie uns in die Kommentare wissen.
Die EA kann die FIFA-Soccer-License auf ihren Sport-Line-Up von Gaming-Experienzen als...
... von der CEO, Andrew Wilson, während einer internen Sitzung geschehen.
Wie sollen die denn weiter FIFA-Ultimate-Team machen, wenn sie keine FIFA-License haben?
... die EAs Ambitions für die Game-Series.
According to Wilson, es bestätigt die EAs Abilität, die die Games pro Jahr aufbauen.
Geht es da nicht nur um die Namen FIFA?
Keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich habe keinen Schimmer, ich verfolge das nicht.
Ich kenne nur die Infos jetzt hier aus dem Video.
Kann aber durchaus sein, ja?
Möglich, keine Ahnung.
... ist vier Letzter vor der Box.
Viele Fans würden sicherlich mit diesem Sentiment begreifen,...
... weil die FIFA-Franchise nur ein wenig mit jedem Verlust ändert.
Wer weiß, welche Experienzen die EAs anbieten könnten,...
... wenn sie volle, artistische Kontrolle über das Spiel hätten.
Das war's für diese Woche im Gaming.
Wie immer, danke fürs Zuschauen.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war Levelcap.
Haben wir nur ein Video geguckt?
Wir sind ja wieder absolut Highspeed unterwegs hier.
Das ist immer so, ja.
Das sind eure Rechte.
Er erzählt uns jetzt die üblichen Geschichten,...
... die mangel und bla und sonst was.
Ich habe letztens was gelesen.
Ich weiß nicht, warum es mir jetzt einfällt.
Erinnert ihr euch noch bei In den USA?
Da hatten sie doch vor einem Jahr, eineinhalb Jahren,...
... diese Aktion, dass man der Polizei Gelder entziehen muss...
... und dass man der Polizei weniger öffentliche Gelder bekommt.
Ich habe jetzt gelesen erst vor ein paar Tagen,...
... dass dort, wo das gemacht wurde,...
... wo man die Polizei weniger Geld gegeben hat,...
... dort, wo die Polizei weniger Mittel zur Verfügung hat,...
... ist die Kriminalität gestiegen.
Da habe ich mir so gedacht, nein,...
... da konnte man ja nicht im Vorfeld von ausgehen.
Wenn die Polizei weniger Geld hat,...
... dann steigt die Kriminalität undenkbar.
Wie hätte man da nur im Vorfeld drauf kommen können?
Unglaublich.
Manchmal verstehe ich die Leute nicht.
Genau, Wasser ist nass.
Nein, wirklich.
Manchmal sind sie so offensichtlich,...
... aber wird trotzdem gemacht.
Max, was hältst du davon,...
... dass Docker von WebAssembly abgelöst wird?
Nichts, weil die zwei Sachen...
... überhaupt nichts miteinander zu tun haben.
Docker ist ein Frontend für die Linux-Container-Funktionalität im Kern.
WebAssembly ist eine Low-Level-Sprache für den Browser...
... als Compile-Target für andere Sprachen.
Das eine hat mit dem anderen eigentlich gar nichts zu tun.
Man kann WebAssembly wie in Docker verwenden.
Äh, nee.
In Docker kann ich zum Beispiel sagen,...
... Docker run eine Postgres-Datenbank.
Also meinst du jetzt irgendjemand cross-compiled...
... Postgres zu Wasm...
... und dann lasse ich Wasm im Browser laufen, oder wie?
Also selbst wenn das möglich ist, würde ich eher sagen...
... nein.
Zumal ich die Datenbank ja eher auch auf dem Backend haben will.
Das Video wurde mir letztens empfohlen.
Okay, Wasm Docker.
Gucken wir uns irgendwann vielleicht mal an.
Ersetzen.
Das war ein deutsches Video, ne?
Hier.
Your browser can't play this video.
Warum?
Das gucken wir jetzt aber nicht.
Hey, den kenne ich.
Ich höre immer...
Der war früher...
Nicht persönlich.
Der war früher.NET MVP.
Der kommt mir bekannt vor.
Frontend-DBs.
Ich weiß nicht.
Datenbank im Frontend mag ja für manche Sachen...
... mag ja für manche Sachen sinnvoll sein.
Aber der Sinn von der Datenbank ist ja unter anderem,...
... dass du dann nicht eine Datenbank pro User hast,...
... sondern eine Datenbank mit mehreren Usern.
Und die im Frontend zu haben, wäre ja etwas fragwürdig,...
... wenn du die Daten aller User bei jedem User im Frontend hast.
Ich denke, das ist wie bei vielem.
Man muss die passende Technologie...
... für den passenden Anwendungszweck benutzen.
Search Destroy Game Reveal, das kenne ich.
Das ist von diesem MW2 Mod.
Da bin ich echt mal gespannt drauf, was da rauskommt, Leute.
Weiß ich, ob ihr das kennt.
Das ist...
Ich weiß gar nicht, für was das steht.
SM2.
Das ist ein Mod, ich glaube, auf der MW2 Engine basierend,...
... wo sie alle möglichen Dinge importiert haben,...
... aus allen möglichen Call of Duty aller Zeiten.
Du hast dann MW2 Waffen, du hast Modern Warfare 3 Waffen,...
... du hast MW1 Waffen, du hast Custom Waffen,...
... Custom Skins, alles Mögliche.
Da bin ich wirklich mal gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Na ja.
Dann ersetzt, wenn da wozu, ist ja die Frage,...
... dann ersetzt das aber auch nicht Docker,...
... weil mit Docker mache ich sowas.
Das sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe,...
... WebAssembly und Docker.
Das ist bestimmt bei manchen Anwendungsfällen,...
... die überlegen, ist es sinnvoll,...
... das in WebAssembly zu compilen und kleinzeitig zu machen,...
... anstatt es als Container auf dem Server laufen zu lassen.
Okay.
Aber ansonsten haben die beiden Technologien...
... nichts miteinander zu tun.
Selbst wenn ich sagen würde, ja, das ist wie,...
... fahre ich mit dem Auto oder fahre ich mit der Bahn,...
... trifft es ja gar nicht.
Da sind zwar zwei unterschiedliche Technologien,...
... aber zum gleichen Zweck.
In dem Fall sind es aber zwei Technologien...
... zu komplett unterschiedlichen Paar Zwecken.
Also das ist so, wie wenn ich sagen würde,...
... Bahn fahren versus Heizung im Keller reparieren.
Das sind auch so zwei komplett unterschiedliche Paar Dinger.
Heizung versus Zug fahren versus Heizung im Keller reparieren.
Das hat auch nichts miteinander zu tun.
Oh.
Es gibt schon Linux in JavaScript.
Irgendjemand hat eine Mini-Version des Linux-Könnels...
... mal zu JavaScript transpiled.
Vor ein paar Jahren schon.
So, weiter geht's.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Karriere im Consulting.
So viel verdient eine Unternehmensberaterin, lohnt sich das.
Okay.
Ich weiß jetzt schon, wenn wir dieses Video gucken,...
... ich werde permanent am lästern sein über Consultants.
Also wenn ihr nicht wollt, dass ich über Consultants lästere,...
... dann dürfen wir jetzt dieses Video nicht gucken.
Ich weiß jetzt schon, dass ich mich schwer zurückhalten kann wahrscheinlich.
Was haben wir sonst noch zur Auswahl?
Seven Ways to Deal with CSS.
Okay, wir gucken jetzt.
Wir gucken das jetzt.
Consulting-Pepega.
Ja.
Also auf geht's.
Ich würde sagen, das Workaholics-Klischee trifft auch nicht zu.
Yes, okay.
Ich würde sagen...
Es gibt zwei Bereiche, wo man eigentlich keine Ahnung haben muss...
... von dem, was man macht.
Das ist diese Geschichte hier.
Und es ist Influencer-Marketing.
Im Prinzip geht es in beiden Bereichen nur...
... um das Vortäuschen von Ahnung.
Um das Vortäuschen von man wüsste, was man tut.
Aber gerade im Bereich Influencer-Marketing...
... hat keiner Ahnung, was er macht.
Außer, und das ist auch das Einzige,...
... dass die Influencer große Sprüche machen und nichts davon halten.
Das sind alles so furchtbar.
Ich will nicht sagen alles.
Ich habe durchaus schon nette Leute getroffen, auch im Influencer.
Wie gesagt, mein Manager ist ein netter Typ.
Der ehemalige Call of Duty Community Manager...
... war auch ein netter Kerl.
Also ich kann sich verallgemeinern.
Nicht alle, nicht alle.
Aber 99% von denen, die ich kennengelernt habe,...
... sind unglaublich...
Man kann auch nicht mal sagen,...
... schleimige Leute, das trifft es nicht.
Das sind Blender.
Das trifft es ganz gut. Blender.
Also es wird alles immer als wahnsinnig easy...
... und groß Five Head verkauft.
Und in Wirklichkeit hat niemand davon eine Ahnung.
Aber es tun alle immer so.
Die reden sich, wenn es dann nicht funktioniert, raus.
Das ist alles ein riesen Blendwerk,...
... dieses ganze Influencer-Marketing-Gedöns.
So. Okay.
Jetzt gucken wir uns mal das an. Was geht hier ab?
Das Workaholic-Klischee trifft auch nicht zu.
Yes, okay. So you're also on the project now.
Was ist das?
120-Hertz-Webcam oder wie?
Guck mal hier. Habt ihr gesehen, wie flüssig...
... die haben hier die neueste Five Head-Technologie?
Spaß daran, auch Geld zu verdienen.
Ich gönne mir gerne mal was,...
... aber ich muss es jetzt nicht aus dem Fenster schmeißen.
Ja, so ist es auch richtig.
Hallo, ich bin Friederike, ich bin 31 Jahre alt...
... und arbeite als Unternehmensberaterin...
... bei dem DT-Con in Köln.
Ist Lautstärke okay oder bist du lauter?
Ich kann Kaffee den ganzen Tag trinken,...
... aber ich versuche nicht mehr, als so ein Ding anzuprinken.
Blooming-Phase, ne?
Kaffee? Ich mag keinen Kaffee.
Ich glaube, ich bin der einzige IT-Mensch, der keinen Kaffee mag.
Dann mache ich nur mal die Schürzen abkippen.
Ich kaufe nicht das billigste von wenigsten,...
... Qualität ist auch schon gut,...
... denke ich ja so, alles das Gleiche, oder?
Ja, da hat sie nicht unrecht.
Ich habe so einen kleinen Aushilfsjob bei einem Kumpel von mir,...
... der hat einen Start-up gegründet,...
... der braucht halt ein bisschen Support...
... und das mache ich immer so ein bisschen außerhalb der Arbeitszeiten,...
... also meistens früh morgens oder spät abends.
Das Start-up kümmert sich um Objectives und Key Results,...
... das ist eine Strategie-Management-Methode.
Okay, jetzt werden erstmal ein paar Buzzwords gedroppt.
Die gerade sehr en vogue ist, sage ich mal.
Ich habe letztens erstmal noch meinen Studienkredit abbezahlt.
Jetzt will ich einfach ein bisschen Geld gerade mal zur Seite legen,...
... weil ich glaube, das ist einfach wichtig,...
... dass man, wenn mal schnell was ist, ein bisschen Geld zur Verfügung hat.
Ich möchte mir in der Zukunft auch gerne...
Wie darf man sich eigentlich ein Start-up vorstellen,...
... was sich um Objectives und Key Results kümmert?
Haben die ein Web-Interface gebaut,...
... wo die die Leute dann anstatt Excel-Tabellen...
... irgendwie was im Web-Interface eintragen...
... und das als AI-unterstützte Cloud-Service,...
... Plattform-Service oder was auch immer?
Irgendwie sowas muss das sein.
Natürlich mal was Eigenes kaufen.
Ein Haus oder eine andere Wohnung.
Stonks, sie kauft sie Stonks, so muss das sein.
Ich hatte ein Meeting mit zwei Arbeitskollegen,...
... bekannten oder Freunden.
Jessica ist in London...
... und der Alex ist in Madrid.
Hallöchen.
Ja, wie geht's euch?
Gut so weit, muss ich sagen.
Wir hatten ein paar Themen.
Das ist nicht Teams, oder? Was ist das? Ist das Zoom?
Ich hatte ja den Workshop am Montag mit dem Team.
Zoomer.
Ja, dann bis bald.
Genau, danke euch auch.
Es ist nicht Teams.
Skype? WebEx?
Ja, was ist es denn jetzt?
Es ist Meet Google. Google Meeting ist es.
Das habe ich noch nie live in Aktionen erlebt, ehrlich gesagt.
Bis dann, tschau tschau.
Sekunde, ich muss noch mal schnell was checken.
Was haben wir in der Taskleiste unten?
Powerpoint.
Ganz wichtig für irgendwie Consultant Action.
Teams, Outlook.
Chrome, Edge.
Ist das ein Terminal?
Nee, das ist eine Stonks App oder sowas wahrscheinlich.
Slack? Ist das Slack?
So wende ich nicht, deswegen kenne ich das Logo nicht.
Das ist Slack.
Shit Tricks auch.
Ohne Shit Tricks geht nichts.
Ich bin mal sehr pragmatisch.
Ich habe lieber eine große Wohnung und teile sie mit einer Person.
Statt wenn ich jetzt so einen kleinen Schuhkarton habe.
Da hätte ich Anfälle bekommen, Leute.
Ich könnte nie im Leben in einer WG wohnen.
Mich fucken echte Menschen eh schon richtig ab.
Zumindest normale Menschen gehen mir mega auf den Keks,
wenn ich denen länger als eine Viertelstunde ausgesetzt bin.
Wenn ich mir überlege,
ich müsste dann auch mit random Leuten in der WG wohnen.
Mehr bezahle, dann habe ich das lieber so.
Aber sehr schöne Auswahl an Chili-Soßen.
Sonst wäre das so, man hat vielleicht daneben ein Büro
und dann kann man sich schnell abstimmen für Dinge.
Hat der Stuhl Armlehnen?
Ja, oder?
Haben wir den Stuhl vorher mal gesehen?
Warten mal, 2.35.
Ich muss mir den Stuhl kurz angucken.
Hat der Armlehnen?
Nee, oder?
Chat, reißt euch mal zusammen.
Keine Sprüche über dicke Leute oder sonst was.
Das muss nicht sein.
Ihr kennt mich, ich bin auch pepofett.
Wenn ich das mache, ist es okay.
Aber einfach random irgendwelche Leute desen,
weil sie ein bisschen Speck haben, ist es wirklich easy.
Das hat keine Armlehnen.
Okay, da kann ich nicht arbeiten dran.
Sonst wäre das so, man hat daneben ein Büro
und dann kann man sich schnell abstimmen für Dinge.
Das ist nicht ergonomisch.
Da tut ihr der Armlehnen vor allem.
Da bin ich sehr viel rumgereist und war auch bei Kunden vor Ort
in Städten in den USA.
Sechs Monate Sub und keine Armlehnen.
Was hat das eine mit dem anderen zu tun?
Diese Gamingstühle sind auch hier.
Deswegen habe ich auch keinen Gamingstuhl.
Deswegen habe ich einen ordentlichen Bürostuhl mit Armlehnen,
die man sogar 3D verstellen kann.
Links, rechts, oben, unten, vorne, hinten.
Kann man die verstellen.
Ich muss aber sagen, ich habe das auch ein bisschen genossen.
Ein bisschen mehr Zeit für einen selber zu haben.
Aber langsam haben alle Berater Hummeln im Hintern
und möchten mal wieder raus.
Das ist der Unterschied zwischen irgendwelchen
sozial-socialisern Beratertypen,
die viel heiße Luft labern und Technikern.
Uns stört das nicht, wenn wir unsere Ruhe haben
und Homeoffice technisch mal was geschafft bekommen.
Diese Leute kriegen Existenzängste, wenn sie nicht mieten können,
den ganzen Tag, um ihre Existenz zu rechtfertigen.
Das mache ich jetzt hier, dass es jetzt mal weitergeht.
Zumindest hat es ein ordentliches Notebook.
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, sie hat ein MacBook,
aber es ist ein Notebook.
Normales.
Man sagt ja auch ein bisschen People-Business zur Beratung.
In People steckt Person und Leute drin.
Das ist schon mal nicht das Richtige für mich.
Ich habe ja keine Kundentermine,
da kann man sich auch ein bisschen legerer anziehen
und die Sneakers auf der Arbeit beziehen.
Also was ich machen würde,
ich hätte wahrscheinlich daheim eine Jogginghose an,
die mich nicht so drückt.
Sneakers auf der Arbeit beziehen.
Ich habe mir das Fahrrad von meinem ersten Gehalt geholt.
Das war für mich so, dass ich...
Das finde ich gut.
Gerade wenn du irgendwo wohnst, wo du drumherum alles hast,
ist Fahrradfahren nicht schlecht.
Wie gesagt, ich habe ja auch so ein uraltes,
will ich sagen, kack Auto, weil ich finde es nicht kacke.
Aber ich würde sagen, die meisten Leute würde sagen,
ich habe ein uraltes kack Auto.
Ich benutze das aber so gut wie nie.
Dafür ist es agil.
Ich benutze das so gut wie nie.
Ich komme zu allem hier drumherum.
Also ohne Probleme, ohne Auto hin.
Und ich muss ehrlich sagen,
ich vermisse das auch nicht.
Zumal, dass die Chance eröffnet,
wenn man da nicht überall mit dem Auto hinfährt,
dass man in einem eh schon relativ bewegungs...
Also in einem nicht so bewegungsintensiven Lebensstil
ein bisschen Bewegung unterzubringen.
Also wenn man ab und zu mal irgendwie zum Bäcker laufen muss
oder zum Supermarkt laufen muss,
oder zum Friseur laufen muss oder sonst was,
wenn es nicht so weit ist, ist das gar nicht mal so verkehrt.
Und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen,
ich weiß, wenn mir das vor 10 Jahren einer gesagt hätte,
hätte ich den auch ausgelacht.
Es ist unglaublich, was ein bisschen Bewegung alles hilft.
Du hast viel weniger Kopfschmerzen,
du hast viel weniger Rückenprobleme,
du hast eigentlich auch...
Du schläfst besser, du bist entspannter.
Also es reicht schon, wenn man sich einfach
ein bisschen tagsüber bewegt.
Es muss gar nicht ein super krasser Fitnessstudio,
Grind oder sowas sein.
Wenn man sich einfach nur ein bisschen bewegt,
ist das unglaublich, wie viel besser man sich fühlt
versus gar nicht nur vom Computer hängen.
Ich meine, das war mir vor 10 Jahren auch klar,
aber ich wollte es nicht hören.
Mittlerweile hatte ich halt schon genug Probleme
von Kopfschmerzen bis Rückenschmerzen und sonst was.
Ich habe gemerkt, dass das alles weggeht
durch ein bisschen Bewegung.
Und da ist, auch wenn es manchmal nervig ist,
ist tatsächlich ein bisschen Bewegung die einfachere Variante.
Mobil sein wollte und in der Stadt ist ja auch alles nah.
Je nachdem, wo mein Projekt ist,
werden dann so Reisekosten ja von der Firma getragen.
Und ab einem gewissen Karrierelevel kann man sich
auch einmal pro Jahr entscheiden,
ob man eine Bahn cut möchte oder ein Auto.
Also wenn ich viel unterwegs wäre,
also wenn ich wirklich auch pünktlich wo ankommen müsste
zu irgendwelchen Meetings,
dann würde ich mich wahrscheinlich wirklich
fürs Auto entscheiden und nicht für die Bahn.
Zum Glück habe ich das Problem nicht.
Ich habe erst mal dagegen entschieden.
Also der dicke Dreier-BMW oder so.
Ja, nee, nicht für mich.
Bei der DT-Con haben wir halt viele Telco-Projekte.
Wir nennen uns Digitalisierungsberatung.
Also unser oberster Schwerpunkt.
Das heißt, die erklären dann irgendwelchen Ultra-Boomern,
dass man was anderes als Fax verwenden kann.
Technisch verbessern kann, darum kümmern wir uns.
Ja, das ist nicht einfach.
Man macht von da nach da und man deinstalliert diese.
Kunde stellt Skype-Verbüsters auf Microsoft Teams um.
Ja, das ist eine gute Idee, das zu machen.
Software und dann holt man sich die Neue rein.
Dafür braucht man Consultants?
Okay.
Warum genau braucht man dafür Consultants?
Das ist doch...
Okay.
Das ist echt verrückt, wie viel da schiefgehen könnte.
Echt?
Und wir versuchen das natürlich zu vermeiden,
weil es ist halt schlecht fürs Geschäft,
wenn die Leute nicht erreichbar sind.
Also ich glaube, von der Skype auf Teams-Umstellung,
da muss man sich schon wirklich Hardcore unfähig anstellen,
dass die Leute nicht mehr miteinander telefonieren können.
Ich meine, ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen,
dass es vielleicht mal ein bisschen Probleme macht,
so nach dem Motto, man hat in Skype irgendwelche Custom-Sachen hinterlegt,
so was weiß ich, Firmenhierarchie,
und das muss man umziehen auf Teams.
Aber so die prinzipielle Funktion ist, dass es einen User gibt,
der sich da drin einloggen kann.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man da so viel verkehrt machen kann.
Ich meine, das ging bei uns auf der Arbeit äußerst problemlos,
und das heißt was, wir verkacken eigentlich so ziemlich alles,
was man verkacken kann in der Richtung.
Wir haben so ein Tool, da bucht man sich online einen Arbeitsplatz,
und da ist man dann quasi gebucht.
Das bin ich ja kurz hier hingefahren.
So ohne ist das nicht.
Was muss man da großartig machen?
Was, nur 75 E-Mails?
Das sind aber Noob-Nummern.
Also ich kriege am Tag bestimmt 400 plus E-Mails.
Das ist jetzt kein Witz, deswegen lese ich die auch nicht mehr.
Ich habe das bei mir auf der Arbeit so gemacht mit E-Mails,
weil wir so viele E-Mails bekommen und so viel E-Mails Spam haben,
so viele unsinnige E-Mails, weil so viele E-Mails
an irgendwelche Verteiler geschickt werden.
Nein, nein, nein, es sind, also Monitoring-Meldungen sind es auch viele,
aber da habe ich einen komplett eigenen Ordner dafür.
Das sind so Sachen wie, wir starten jetzt Deployment XY,
und ich bin dann halt im Verteiler drin für irgendwas,
was mich nicht interessiert.
Oder irgendwie, was weiß ich, Abteilung XY hat jetzt neue Mitarbeiter.
Oder bitte guckt mal hier in dieses Ticket rein.
Oder hier wurde ein neues Ticket erstellt und bla, bla, bla, bla.
Also irgendwie, was weiß ich, 400 Tickets ist denke ich gar nicht mal so sehr übertrieben.
Wahrscheinlich ist das sogar bei einem Tag, wo viel abgeht, sogar noch zu wenig.
Die Sache ist plus die, dass es total schwachsinnig ist,
zu meinen, man könnte sich das angucken.
Was benutzen wir am Outlook?
Ich habe es so gemacht, ich habe einen Ordner,
ich habe eine Inbox und ich habe einen Ordner,
ich habe einen Monitoring-Ordner, wo alles Zappix rein gefiltert wird.
Aber ich habe es so gemacht, ich mache nur noch Whitelist.
Also sprich, alle E-Mails bleiben in der Inbox, außer E-Mails,
die direkt an mich gehen oder direkt an mich in CC gehen.
Die kommen in einen extra Ordner und nur noch in diesen Ordner, guck ich rein.
Und dann ist es natürlich viel, viel weniger.
Dann hat sie mit Sicherheit mehr, weil ich glaube, von diesen 75 Mails,
die sie bekommt, die sind ja wahrscheinlich auch wirklich für sie relevant.
Aber ich habe dann vielleicht, was weiß ich, vier, fünf am Tag oder so,
die wirklich auch relevant sind.
Die restlichen Sachen gehen direkt über Teams.
Es schreibt dann eigentlich in der Richtung kaum noch einer Mails.
Aber der restliche Spam ist einfach nicht, ist einfach unnormal bei uns.
Und manchmal beschwert sich dann irgendjemand, ja, du hast meine Mails nicht gesehen.
Hab ich gesagt, ja, hast du die an mich geschickt?
Nein, nein, ich habe die an den Verteiler XY geschickt.
Ich habe gesagt, ja gut, seh ich nicht mehr.
Verteiler XY landet bei mir nicht im Ordner an mich.
Pech.
Ja, aber ich brauche jetzt erstmal Wasser und einen Kaffee.
Da gehen wir jetzt mal hin.
Wie lange die Projekte dann sind, das ist halt immer total unterschiedlich.
Es gibt halt manche Projekte, die sind mal nur ein paar Tage oder eine Woche.
Ich hatte jetzt meistens immer so relativ längere Projekte,
wo ich immer so sechs bis neun Monate bei einem Kunden war.
Das ist auch hier alles so von Designern übrigens gemacht.
Das ist auch ganz nett.
Ja, so sieht es ja auch aus.
Also genau, also das dieser Punkt, dieser Punkt an der Wand,
das muss ein richtig krasser Designer gewesen sein.
Übrigens gemacht, das ist auch ganz nett.
Richtig, richtig.
Wow.
Ist das grün durch die grünen Vorhänge oder ist da RGB am Start?
Künstlern so, um ein bisschen ja so ein New Work Ansatz reinzubringen.
Oh Gott, das ist mir zu hipster.
Das ist mir schon, das ist mir deutlich, deutlich zu zoomer hipster.
So haben.
Plötzlich Probleme, wichtige Daten fehlen.
Für allen müssen da wohl auch Nummer hinterlegt sein.
Das habe ich ganz unten hingeschrieben und die fehlen irgendwie.
Also das hatte der Harald gesagt.
Okay, aber die arbeitet.
Wisst ihr, woran man sieht, dass die arbeitet?
Die benutzt eine Maus und nicht ihr komisches Hipster Touchpad
wie die anderen letztens.
Die macht wenigstens richtig was.
Also irgendwie heute ging mal so ein bisschen.
Also alle, die nur mit dem Touchpad arbeiten,
arbeiten meiner Ansicht nach eh nicht.
Die tun einfach nur so.
Alles, was schief geben könnte, dann haben wir erst mal bemerkt,
irgendwie war die Liste nicht vorhanden.
Dann hatte sie jemand irgendwie einen Papierkorb verschoben.
Und dafür brauchen wir einen Konsult.
Jetzt erklärt, jetzt erklärt es mir auch,
warum so viele Konsult gebraucht werden.
Wenn du dafür schon Konsulten brauchst,
dann ist klar, dass es aus dem Boden spriegt überall.
Alles klar, danke.
Also wenn du schon Konsulten anrufen musst,
weil irgendjemand eine Liste in Papierkorb verschoben hat,
dann ist vorbei.
Dann ist aber wirklich durch.
Wofür braucht man als IT deine Maus?
Zum Beispiel für deinen Browser.
Zum Beispiel, um Teams zu bedienen.
Zum Beispiel, um irgendwie ein hässliches Outlook,
was ich nicht haben will, aber trotzdem habe, bedienen zu können,
generell für einen Browser.
Um Sachen zu spielen.
Natürlich brauchst du eine Maus.
Terminal Only ist heute einfach nicht mehr,
auch wenn das die ganzen Hardcore-Wim-Leute nicht wahrhaben wollen.
Ich hab meine Keys, nur auf der Home-Row.
Alles klar.
Bis dann, ciao.
Viel Spaß, wenn du aufs Stackoverflow gehen musst.
Ich hoffe, die kriegen das dann wieder schnell hin.
Weil wenn irgendwann mal was schiefgeht,
dann werde ich nach ein paar Daten gefragt
und suche die halt raus und stelle den Leuten zur Verfügung.
Aber die technischen Lösungen mache ich halt dann nicht.
Okay, wozu braucht man sie dann?
Also was ist denn jetzt,
was genau ist ihre Daseinsberechtigung jetzt?
Außer Geld zu kosten.
Früher, als noch nicht Pandemie war,
da hab ich mir dann auch auf das was mitgenommen.
Auch um einfach ein bisschen Geld zu sparen.
Aber jetzt bin ich ja nur so ein, zwei Mal pro Woche im Office.
Und dann geh ich immer auch mit den Kollegen essen.
Das ist ja dann auch geselligart.
Guten Appetit.
Jetzt erst mal schön anhusten.
Ich geh aber auch schnell weiter.
Für den nächsten Termin.
Und da brauch ich ein bisschen Ruhe.
Deswegen suche ich mir jetzt mal einen Lauf.
Da ist doch überhaupt nichts.
Da sitzt eine Person im Büro.
Da ist doch Ruhe.
Aber gut, das kann ich verstehen.
Das kann ich wirklich sehr gut nachvollziehen.
Ich hasse es, wenn Leute dabei sind,
wenn ich länger telefonieren muss.
Also mal kurz irgendwie so nach dem Motto,
hier, keine Ahnung, mach mal kurz Silence im Monitoring oder so.
Ist kein Problem.
Aber wenn ich länger und kompliziertere Sachen
besprechen muss, dann verpisse ich mich auch meistens irgendwo anders hin.
Ich mag das auch nicht,
wenn ich Leute rumrennen habe neben mir
und ich bin länger am Telefonieren.
Jetzt geht es darum zu schauen,
dass die Daten, die ich vorher gesammelt habe
mit den Ansprechpartnern an den Standorten
und diese andere Firma
hat jetzt daraus dieses Dokument erstellt.
Und jetzt muss ich halt gucken,
dass die Daten richtig sind.
Alter, was ein Aufwand.
Und was für ein manuelles
Excel-Geschupse.
What the fuck?
Das sind ja Drossler-Projekte, die eigentlich easy umzusetzen sind,
Millionen kosten.
Wer überrascht, wenn es mal einwandfrei läuft,
aber es sind immer die gleichen Copy-Paste-Fehler,
die die irgendwie reinmachen.
Leute, es gibt durchaus
Möglichkeiten, Daten auszutauschen,
ohne dass man sie per Excel
copypastet, per E-Mail verschickt
und in einem anderen Unternehmen aus der Excel wieder rauscopypastet.
Alter.
Nicht schlimm.
Aber deswegen haben wir ja so mehrere Augenprinzip.
Good afternoon.
Hi. I'm doing great.
We have to look at this again, but...
Ich meine, das ist die Realität. Das ist so.
Ja, natürlich. Ich weiß, dass es die Realität ist.
Es gibt so viele
fails. Zum Beispiel,
könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, als bei der
Internationalen Raumstation irgendein Modul
nicht andocken konnte, weil die einen in Inches
gemessen haben und die anderen in Zentimeter.
Also so
einfache easy-Fehler sind die Tagesordnung.
But at least
it's...
I'm sort of correct until the end
in the middle of next year. That's already a good
thing. Wenn man
Unternehmensberatung machen möchte, kann es jeder
probieren. Und ich glaube,
es gibt eine Unternehmensberatung, die einen einstellt.
Ich glaube, ich muss mich davon...
Ich glaube, ich muss... Ich glaube, jetzt habe ich es
verstanden. Ich glaube, ich muss mir abschminken.
Das Unternehmensberatung
bedeutet, man muss
sonderlich...
Soll ich sagen? Man muss sonderlich
krasse Dinger können. Das ist
gar nicht so. Ich glaube, es reicht schon, wenn man
normale Dinger kann, weil es gibt
genug Unternehmen, die noch blöder sind,
die quasi
bei den einfachsten Dingern schon
Consulting brauchen, weil sie zu
den einfachsten Sachen selbst nicht in
der Lage sind.
Ich bin ja bisher immer rangegangen
mit der Sache, wozu brauche ich
alle Consultants, die ich so kenne,
haben eigentlich
keinen Plan. Aber
die haben genug Plan,
weil es gibt genug, die noch viel weniger
Ahnung haben und bei den einfachen Dingern
eigentlich schon Hilfe brauchen.
So wird das wahrscheinlich sein. Du musst gar nicht
super krass als Consultant sein.
Deswegen gibt es auch so viele Junior-Consultants,
die noch weniger Ahnung haben.
Da müsste man jetzt mal den Niklas fragen.
Der Niklas ist ja Consultant. Der kennt sich mit
sowas aus. Wenn es dann
nicht passt, dann merkt man das im Job.
Als Unternehmensberater kann man sich nicht verstecken.
Also hilft es, glaube ich,
sich vielen...
Das Gegenteil von Verstecken musst du machen.
Du musst präsent sein, ohne
Ahnung zu haben. Das ist
auch ein Skill, den man haben muss.
Also man muss quasi auch von Dingern,
wo man keine Ahnung hat, so tun können, als hätte man Ahnung.
...gestellt zu haben und dann
extrovertiert da dran zu gehen
und die Dinge in die Hand zu nehmen und
versuchen... Ja, das wäre nichts für mich.
Thank you to you. Da muss ich
echt sagen, Hut ab von den Leuten, die das können.
Ich bin nach 15
Minuten schon
ultra sauer,
wenn es andere... Also ich hasse
Sachen fünfmal erzählen zu müssen,
wenn es die Leute nicht verstehen. Also ich kriege
wirklich... Ich drehe
komplett am Rad.
Also ich bin
nicht gut da drin im
Zusammenarbeiten mit Nicht-Technikern
oder mit Ahnungslosen
Technikern. Ich bin wirklich
ziemlich schnell genervt, was sowas angeht.
Und
gerade wenn ich Sachen
doppelt und dreifach
sagen muss und es mir dann
versucht, einer zu erklären, wie er es verstanden
hat. Das stimmt nicht. Ich bin da sau schnell
mega angepisst und das
darfst du in diesem Job nicht sein. Deswegen muss ich echt sagen,
musst du Hut ab. Also du musst quasi
eine hohe
Leidensresistenz
haben und dir immer
denken, hey, für jedes Mal,
wo ich dir den gleichen Easy-Kram
nochmal erkläre, kriege ich Geld.
Und wenn du dir das im Hinterkopf denkst, kannst du sowas wahrscheinlich
auch machen.
Ansonsten...
Ich würde auch... Ich würde auch schlimmen.
Wenn mich einer anruft, weil in irgendeinem Excel irgendwo was
drin ist oder sowas nicht stimmt,
dann regt es mich schon immer auf, wenn sie sagt dem Motto, Alter,
was soll ich mich mit irgendeiner komischen Kack Excel-Liste
beschäftigen oder so.
Das hat ein bisschen länger gedauert.
Frustrationstoleranz.
Ich habe eigentlich eine relativ
hohe Frustrationstoleranz,
aus dem Grund, weil mir 99% der Sachen
komplett am Arsch vorbeigehen.
Die Sache ist bloß, bei den Sachen,
die mir nicht am Arsch vorbeigehen, da ist meine
Frustrationstoleranz sehr gering.
Also wir machen 99%
überhaupt nichts aus, juckt mich nicht.
Ihr merkt es ja auch hier, manchmal dreht der Chat
voll am Rad und es gibt Dinge, das
interessiert mich alles überhaupt nicht.
Die meisten Sachen selbst, wenn einer hier richtig
krass reinschiebaded und rumtrollt im Chat,
meins meiste juckt mich das nicht.
Im Zweifel, wenn die Leute gebannt. Aber es gibt
so manche Kombinationen.
Das regt mich auf.
Und ihr habt
es ja wahrscheinlich schon gemerkt, Chat.
Eine Sache, die mich persönlich extrem
aufregt, ist
so Backseating, so besser
Wissen, aber ohne Ahnung zu haben.
Das nervt mich.
Wenn ich beispielsweise in irgendeinem Programmier-Stream hier
was ausprobieren will.
Ich bin zu blöd und ich krieg's nicht hin.
Und dann hast du im Chat einen, der 10
Minuten lang den gleichen Mist spammt,
was ich jetzt machen soll,
und er selbst keine Ahnung hat.
Und es stimmt nicht, was er sagt.
Oder es ist irgendwas, wo ich selbst schon vor 5
Minuten dran gedacht habe und weiß, das
kann's nicht sein. Und er erzählt
das immer wieder.
Und das regt mich
auf. Das regt mich immer.
Manchmal haben wir so Leute im Chat.
Die sind dann immer, die sind dann
noch Backseating. Nee, ich hab damit
keine Schmerzen. Ich sag ja oft genug auch.
Habt ihr irgendwie eine Idee, gerade
wenn's um CSS oder sowas geht, wo ich keine Ahnung
davon hab. Habt ihr eine Idee, wie man das machen
kann? Da gibt's ja Leute wie den Auskennfuchs zum Beispiel.
Der sagt dann, ja, hier mach einfach
CSS-Crit, Gap-Margin
minus 25, Top
Align Left. Und dann mach ich das und
dann funktioniert's. Da weiß ich, okay,
der Typ hat Plan.
Und dann hast du andere Leute im Chat,
die 5 mal
in einer Minute das Gleiche
posten. Und eine
Sache, wo ich schon weiß, dass es schwachsinnig
ist. Und das regt mich auf.
X-Mats
sagt, wir Backseaten die
Consulterin. Die Consultin können wir nicht Backseaten.
Die Consultin ist ja nicht live. Wir sagen ja nicht,
was sie machen soll. Außerdem, der Beitrag
erzählt uns ja auch gar nicht, was sie macht.
Außer Excel-Listen korrigieren.
Ja, das war jetzt auch wieder
witzig. Also,
das geht
drauf und drüber mit den Jungs. Also, das ist
halt keiner von
meinen Kunden, sondern das ist eine andere Firma,
mit dem ich gesprochen habe.
Und die sind sehr nett, natürlich.
Aber
er hatte jetzt vergessen,
die Sachen abzuspeichern, die wir beim
letzten Mal gemacht haben.
Wisst ihr was?
Ich glaube, das war nur eine Ausrede.
Das war nur eine Ausrede.
Der wollte Ruhe vor der
Consultin haben.
Das war nur eine
Ausrede. 100 Pro.
Das ist so ein Ding,
das sehe ich mich.
Das sehe ich mich auch. Wenn ich wüsste,
wenn ich wüsste, ich habe irgendeinen nervigen Termin
mit irgendeiner Consultin, die mir auf den Keks
geht, weiß ich nicht, ob das
so ist.
Da könnte ich mir durchaus auch
vorstellen, dass ich so eine Ausrede bringe.
So nach dem Motto AVM hat Verbindungen
abgebrochen. Jetzt weiß ich leider nicht mehr,
wo wir stehengeblieben sind oder irgendwie sowas.
Also, das ist durchaus eine
Ausrede, die man sich,
wenn man keinen Bock auf das Meeting
hat.
Einfach so Sachen,
das geht eigentlich nicht.
Ich von Unternehmensberatung
könnte mir das nicht leisten, würde ich mal so sagen.
Und ich würde auch so eigentlich
nicht in Termin rauskommen.
Ist jetzt nicht dramatisch, ist jetzt kein
Weinbruch. Aber wäre schöner gewesen,
es fertig zu machen.
Ich glaube, die haben einfach keinen Bock auf
die Beraterin. Das war
ihr Trick, sich rauszureden
aus dem Meeting
mit der Beraterin.
Was sie
jetzt genau berät, habe ich auch nicht verstanden.
Exelisten kopieren.
Es kommt auf das Projekt an, wieviel
Druck ist oder wieviel Druck dahinter
steckt. Manchmal gibt es wirklich
Kunden, die sind
nicht so einfach.
Ich habe das jetzt nett ausgedrückt.
Und die erwarten sehr viel
von dir. Es gibt aber auch
Kunden, die sind nicht so. Und ich glaube,
es macht halt Spaß,
beides mal zu erleben.
Ich glaube, die, die sehr viel erwarten,
das sind bestimmt auch oftmals
die, die erwarten so viel, weil sie eigentlich
keine Ahnung haben, was die eigentlich wollen.
Das sind dann irgendwelche Leute, die sagen, okay,
bleiben wir mal dieser Skype zu Teams
Umstellung, so nach dem Motto, ja,
wir wollen keinen Skype haben, wir wollen was anderes,
können sie uns beraten.
Und dann sag ich, was, wie, was
wollt ihr denn jetzt eigentlich genau haben? Ja, sagen
sie uns das doch. Das sind dann
solche Leute, die gar keinen Plan
haben und meinen so nach dem Motto, okay,
wir holen uns mal Beratung
für etwas, wo wir selber nicht mal wissen, in welche
Richtung es gehen soll.
Außerdem,
ganz schön
viel erwartet von den Leuten, dass sie ihr
Zeug speichern, oder?
Wie sehr stört dich das Telefon
bei der Arbeit? Hast du ein ähnliches Konzept wie
bei E-Mails? Telefon,
Telefon ist,
seit ich dauer Homeoffice habe und Teams nicht
so sehr das Problem. Die meisten Leute melden
sich in Teams und in Teams stelle ich mich
einfach auf nicht stören.
Ich glaube, unheimlich viel lernt, wenn man so
einen etwas anstrengenderen
Kunden hatte. Ich hatte
auch schon Kollegen,
die wirklich immer
sehr auf Zack sein mussten, weil der Kunde
auch mal um 10 Uhr abends anruft oder so,
oder noch irgendwie mit dem
um neun Termin reinstellt,
um Dinge zu besprechen.
Das hatte ich auch schon, da sage ich immer ab.
Zusammen aus meinem Grundgehalt
von der Detekon, dann haben wir noch
ein Bonusgehalt,
das sich daraus ergibt,
dass ich meine Ziele erreiche.
Und dann habe ich noch einen Nebenjob
bei Wave 9, der kommt auch noch
on top quasi in der Tour. Der Bonus
setzt sich zusammen aus der Utilisation,
die sollte mindestens 80 Prozent sein,
also dass ich mindestens 80 Prozent meiner Arbeitszeit
auf Projekte buche
und dann noch die Projektnote, die sollte
bei mindestens 3 liegen oder besser.
Ich bin jetzt...
Moment, das habe ich nicht verstanden. Was? Hä?
Meine Arbeitszeit auf Projekte buche
und dann noch die Projektnote,
die sollte bei mindestens 3 liegen.
Eine Projektnote?
Ach, das ist
die Arbeit
bei irgendeiner Consultingfirma
und am Ende
dieses Projekts,
dürfen die Kunden quasi
eine Note abgeben, wie zufrieden sie mit ihrem
Consultant waren, so nach dem Motto.
Und daraufhin sagt dann ihr Chef,
hast du gut gemacht oder nicht?
Irgendwie sowas.
3 liegen oder besser. Ich bin jetzt
vom Business Analyst zum Consultant
befördert worden und
damit einhergeht auch, dass ich um die
20 Prozent mehr... Wahnsinn! Jetzt kann man anderen
Titel aufs Schildchen schreiben.
...gehalt bekomme. Das erfahre ich jetzt
mit meiner nächsten Gehaltsabrechnung.
20 Prozent?
Das ist nicht schlecht. Mehr?
Oh, ordentlich.
18 Uhr eine typische
Feierabendzeit?
Eigentlich nicht ganz so früh.
18 Uhr, Alter! Boah!
Ich bin 15 Uhr weg.
15.30 Uhr.
15.30 Uhr fällt bei mir
der Hammer, wie man so schön sagt.
Eigentlich
ein bisschen zu früh.
Aber ich habe jetzt
noch was vor und deswegen muss man sich die Zeit auch mal
legen. Ja, ich würde sagen,
das Workaholic-Klischee trifft auf
mich zu.
Das...
Ja, ich sitze manchmal länger
am PC als ich vielleicht sollte oder auch will.
Das kennen wir alle.
Aber
da gibt es dann einfach Aufgaben, die mir Spaß
machen und dann möchte ich die auch noch
fertig machen oder einfach Aufgaben, die fertig
gemacht werden müssen.
Prost!
Auf uns, dass ihr da seid.
Wir machen einen Rundlauf, oder?
Ja.
Oder willst du alleine von uns fertig gemacht
werden? Also unter
der Woche muss man sich auch mal
Zeit für sowas nehmen.
Das sieht so hässlich aus im Hintergrund.
Das ist bestimmt Berlin oder sowas.
Oder wo ist das?
Weiß man, welche Stadt das ist?
Ach, das ist Köln. Okay, da gibt es auch...
Es könnte auch Frankfurt sein, ganz ehrlich.
So hässliche Ecken gibt es überall, aber okay.
Aber irgendwie
sind ja auch alle in meinem Alter
berufstätig und haben dann nicht immer
so viel Zeit. Heißkill!
Aber muss halt auch mal sein.
Gerade wenn die Freunde so nah wohnen,
ist das doch schön, ne?
Da sieht man,
das sind einfach unterschiedliche
Leute.
Ich würde mich wahrscheinlich im Leben nicht
mit den Leuten...
Ich kenne sogar eigentlich zu wenig
Leute vor Ort, mit denen ich überhaupt
Tischtennis spielen könnte, die das machen würden.
Aber selbst mit den Leuten, die ich in der Nähe
hätte, mit denen ich Tischtennis spielen
gehen könnte, würde ich nicht
mit ihnen spielen gehen.
Das ist mir zu viele offline,
soziale offline Interaktionen.
Aber
okay, warum nicht jeder? Jeder
ist eins. Also das höchste der Gefühle,
was ich mache oder gemacht habe, jetzt mit
spätestens seit Corona, ist ja vorbei.
Ich bin mit dem Felix ab und zu
mal Squash spielen gegangen.
Könnt ihr euch vorstellen, zwei Pepo-Fat-Leute
gehen Squash spielen. Alter, wir waren so
im Arsch. Wir waren immer so
krass extrem
im Arsch danach. Das ist echt der Wahnsinn
gewesen. So im Arsch war ich
noch nie.
Und wir haben noch nicht mal volle Pulle gespielt.
Weil mir das sonst gar nicht durchhält.
Ich meine, es ist
vorbei mit dem Squash spielen, spätestens
seit Corona. So habe ich das gemeint.
Corona ist auch nicht vorbei. Dafür bin ich auch viel zu
sehr am Husten gerade.
Aber der ist da noch dran gewesen.
Ey, wie krass bist du denn?
Hier so, so drangeschlittert.
Richtig fies.
Für mich
lohnt es sich, weil ich
viel lerne, viel Spaß bei der
Arbeit habe, spannende Projekte habe,
viel daraus lerne und die
Bezahlung. Also wir haben jetzt nicht wirklich gelernt,
was sie eigentlich macht, oder?
Habt ihr irgendeinen Plan davon,
was sie eigentlich genau macht?
Außer
Listen kopieren?
Weil es schon ganz okay ist.
3.352 Euro Netto.
Okay. Das ist aber gar nicht
so viel?
Weil für 55
Stunden?
Das ist, das ist,
das ist überhaupt
nicht viel.
55 Stunden?
Ich meine, natürlich bekommt die mehr als ich
überwiesen im Monat. Aber ich arbeite auch nur
vier Tage die Woche und wenn ich arbeite, fällt nur
530 der Hammer.
Das war kein Wunder.
Also ich arbeite ungefähr
die Hälfte, na ja,
ja.
Ich arbeite ungefähr die Hälfte von der.
Ich arbeite 30
Stunden und die arbeitet 55.
Also ich arbeite ungefähr die Hälfte von
ihr.
Und ich kriege
überwiesen am Ende des Monats
mehr als die Hälfte
davon. Also
die kann ich nicht verdienen.
Also es ist
für 55 Stunden finde ich das
nicht, nicht viel.
Da hätte ich jetzt eigentlich gedacht
als krasser Consultant kriegste mehr.
Ach ne, da
kommt noch mal was oben drauf oder wie?
Ne.
Moment.
Hä?
Ey Moment, das ist das was übrig bleibt
oder was?
Moment.
Das ist aber echt nicht viel. Also ich hätte
gedacht das ist deutlich mehr.
Was man
kriegt.
Geht nicht so viel.
Ich meine 55 Stunden, 55 Stunden
die Woche arbeiten heißt im Endeffekt
du machst eigentlich außer arbeiten nicht
mehr irgendwas anderes.
Dafür ist es echt nicht viel.
Ich hoffe euch hat gefallen zu sehen wie ich lebe und arbeite.
Wenn ihr weitere Berufe
kennenlernen wollt, könnt ihr das hier oder
hier tun. Und am
End.
Den hatten wir schon geguckt, ne?
Der war cool der Typ. Das war der der
Förster ist abends.
Das Video zu liken
oder den Channel zu abonnieren und dann
wünsche ich euch auch alles Gute
bei eurer Berufswahl.
Ich hätte echt gedacht
als
FyFat Unternehmens hier
Consultant kriegt man mehr.
Das haut mich jetzt nicht
so sehr vom Hocker.
Max du hattest
bei Sveld ein Eigenpack das aus
mehreren Icons bestand. Wie hieß das?
Ich hatte mehrere Sachen. Ich hatte einmal Hero Icons.
Hero Icons ist eigentlich ganz
nice, weil du dir die Sachen direkt
als SVG
kopieren kannst und
dementsprechend so direkt in deinen Editor
einfügen kannst. Hero Icons
hatte ich. Oder
was ich auch mal irgendwann verwendet habe,
ist glaube ich Iconify.
Da kannst du dann alle möglichen Icon
Fonts durchsuchen.
Wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel was weiß ich
Arrow suchst, dann hast du dann
irgendwie alle möglichen Icon Fonts, kannst
dir dann das Richtige raussuchen.
Aber ich mag Hero Icons, weil
du das einfach Copy Pasten kannst und gut ist.
Ja, bei Iconify ist Font Awesome
unter anderem mit durchsucht.
Ich gehe davon
ganz ehrlich,
Ateno, ich gehe sogar davon aus, dass das im großen
Stil so ist, weil
ich weiß damals,
ich wurde ja auch mal verschachert,
bei Provider, wo ich mal
ursprünglich gearbeitet habe, meine Ausbildung gemacht habe.
Die haben uns verkauft,
zwar nicht
menschenhandelstechnisch, aber
so ungefähr in die Richtung. Die haben uns
verkauft an beispielsweise eine Bank in
Frankfurt als
IT Leute.
Wir haben dann dort quasi offiziell uns um das
Rechenzentrum gekümmert von denen.
Und ich habe
mal gehört, was die im Monat
für uns bezahlt haben, versus
das, was wir im Monat bekommen haben.
Die haben, glaube ich,
um die 20.000 Euro pro Person bezahlt.
Und ratet
mal, wie viel von diesen 20.000
Euro am Ende bei uns angekommen ist.
Also ich kann euch sagen,
wenn ihr eine Null weglasst, dann geht das ungefähr
in die Richtung.
Nenne ich ganz sauer. Naja.
So, und ich gehe davon aus, dass das
da auch so sein wird.
Dass die irgendwelche
bezahlbaren
Consultant Leute
sich holen für so, für die 0815
Dinger.
Und die verkaufen die halt dann
mega teuer. Und die Consultants
werden dann okay bezahlt.
Aber das Unternehmen, also quasi
was diese Consultants vermittelt,
die werden wahrscheinlich richtig krass abgreifen.
Ja, nicht, dass du was Falsches
kopierst oder nicht abspeichert.
Du brauchst einen Consultant, ja klar.
Das ist nicht der erste Job.
Siehst du, er ist letztens befördert worden. Das kann nicht der erste Job sein.
Nice, okay.
Was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Kurz refreshen.
Also was haben wir als nächstes noch
zu bieten hier? Anwitz.
Was? LPL?
Wer ist denn LPL?
Hat der Lockpicking Lawyer?
Hat er
hat er irgendwas spannendes wieder?
Did I cheat?
Nein, er hat wahrscheinlich
irgendein Special Tool
am Start wieder, was er
zufälligerweise vorher hergestellt hat
oder so.
Okay.
Gucken wir uns mal kurz an,
wie das Lock gepickt wird.
Jawoll.
Das Government.
FBI, open up.
Ja gut, nur
da muss ich jetzt an der Stelle was zu sagen, ist ja schön und gut,
aber diese Dinger sind ja auch den ganzen Tag
beaufsichtigt, irgendwelche Postfächer.
Und ja,
ist schön, wenn du so einen Lock
easy knacken kannst, aber
wenn die beaufsichtigt werden,
die Postfächer, ist halt schwierig, mal kurz
sein Lockpicking Tool rauszuholen
und da ein bisschen dran rumzuschrauben.
Ach so, in Apartments.
Ja, dann ist es für'n Arsch.
Ja, so schwer kann das ja nicht sein.
Das Video geht noch 59 Sekunden lang
und er ist noch beim Einspannen.
Der guckt es jetzt scharf an und dann ist es auf.
Ach den.
Ah, das kenne ich.
Das habe ich schon öfters gesehen bei ihm.
Der steckt es jetzt rein und wackelt dann einfach
Gachibas mit dem Schloss
und dann ist es auf.
Das haben wir schon öfters gesehen.
Guck.
Das ist ein Schlossöffnungskonsultant, genau.
Ja, ziemlich schlecht, oder?
Na, wahrscheinlich erlauben die dir das nicht,
dass sie selbst easy reinkommen.
Okay, 7 Ways to Deal mit CSS.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Festplatte von eBay.
Ich habe Schreckliches gefunden.
Wir gucken uns das mal an.
7 Wege CSS und dann gucken wir,
ich habe Schreckliches gefunden.
Was wäre ein Rambock,
ein mittelalterlicher Schlossöffnungskonsultant?
Na, der Rambock nicht,
sondern derjenige,
der mit dem Rambock rammt vielleicht.
CSS ist abfuck.
CSS ist so...
Es gibt CSS-Fans.
Ich weiß, es gibt auf YouTube ein paar Channels,
die machen sogar CSS-Challenges.
Oder das neueste,
was ich jetzt gesagt habe,
CSS-Battles.
Da gibt es dann zwei Leute,
die sagen, okay, wir bauen jetzt das und das nach
und was ultra kompliziert ist,
und wer es am besten nachbaut, gewinnt und sowas.
CSS-Battles, so weit sind wir schon gekommen, ja.
Das Video, not recommended, okay.
Was du gelernt hast, ich habe mal
irgendwann vor Urzeiten Fachinformatiker
und Webintegration gelernt.
Das ist aber schon ganz lange her.
Ah, erst mal ein bisschen Eigenwerbung eingestreut, top.
Da macht er sowas.
Global CSS, Leute.
Haines-Champ.
Was zum Teufel ist BEM?
Chet,
ihr dürft jetzt backseaten.
Was ist BEM?
BEM wie Bruce Lee.
CSS, CSS.
BEM?
Get BEM Instructions.
Block Element Modifier.
Was?
Von den China-Chinesen wurde das entwickelt.
So ist... ach ne.
Moment, Yandex ist nicht China.
Das ist Niederlande, das habe ich
durchaus angebracht. Russisch ist es sogar.
Oh.
Commodates am Start.
Block Element
Modifier BEM.
Hä?
Hab ich...
Welcher Ausgeburt der Hölle ist das denn,
was ich hier sehe?
Oh Gott, bitte nicht!
Brand Board Recommendation Titles.
Okay, gucken wir mal weiter.
Obbei, irgendjemand an dem Chat
kann noch was gefragt, zeigt mal her.
Mal aus reinem technischen
Interesse, die typische Beschäftigung
eines Hackers erfordert das doch...
Was? Erfordert man auch viel
Netzwerktechnisches Know-How oder
was? Also, wenn du nach Jobbezeichnung
suchst, niemand sucht einen Hacker
als Jobbezeichnung.
Und dann kommt's ganz entscheidend darauf
an, in welchem Bereich du was machst.
Ich mein, das kann man jetzt gar nicht
so allgemein sagen. Ich mein, Netzwerk-Grundlagen
gehört auf jeden Fall in so
ziemlich jedem Bereich dazu.
Gerade weil du halt gerne mal bei der Übertragung
irgendwelche Dinge mitschneidest und
reingucken musst. Also
Netzwerktechnisch-Grundlagen und so brauchst du
eigentlich für alles. Ansonsten kommt's drauf an,
in welchem Bereich du was machst.
Das, was man so über Anonymous
hört, ja, das kommt auch drauf an. Die haben
ja sicherlich auch nicht nur...
Die machen ja auch nicht nur eine Sache.
Ich hab letztens gelesen, dass irgendwelche
Hackermans russische
Fernsehsender angeblich gehackt haben, sodass
da die ukrainische Nationalhymne läuft.
Weiß nicht, ob da was dran ist.
Hab ich auf Reddit gelesen. Auf Reddit ist das immer ein bisschen...
Ja, man weiß es nicht so genau, ob das stimmt.
Und da kommt's halt auch drauf an.
Je nachdem,
was die Leute machen wollen, musst du dich in unterschiedlichen
Bereichen auskennen. Wie eigentlich
so ziemlich überall.
Also, wenn du dich jetzt zum Beispiel
damit beschäftigst,
wie kann ich in die Switch...
Wie kann ich auf der Switch
Custom-Firmware laufen lassen, oder
die Leute, die damals versucht haben, aus der Playstation
den Private Key
auszulesen und so was.
Da weiß ich nicht, ob du
da so wahnsinnig krass durch mir Netzwerk
auskennen musst. Da geht's
eher Richtung,
dass du dich mit Hardware gut auskennst
und mit Elektronik gut auskennst.
Das kommt ganz drauf an, was du machen willst.
Genau, genau.
Ich gehe mal davon aus,
dass man so ein paar Grundlagen
natürlich aus allen möglichen Bereichen
weiß, ja.
Das ist so, wie ich beispielsweise Java
lesen kann, aber mir im Leben nichts
in Java programmieren möchte. Oder ich kann
auch Swift lesen, ohne dass ich jemals was
in Swift gemacht hab. Ja, ich kann ja
auch so die grundsätzlichen Sachen sagen,
von einem Wireshark-Dump oder so,
was ich da sehe.
Aber ich könnte dir jetzt nicht sagen,
ah, okay, das zweite Bit hier ist
jetzt hier 2e.
Das bedeutet, das ist
das zweite Paket
vom Handshake des
Service XY, weil da 2e drin steht.
Keine Ahnung.
Was weiß ich?
Ich bin ja gar nicht wirklich Software-Entwickler.
Das ist einfach ein Thema, also Programmieren
und so. Das ist etwas, was mich interessiert.
Und ich hab das Glück, dass ich
mittlerweile relativ viel
in meinem Daily-Job
halt auch Richtung
Software-Entwicklung machen kann. Oder zumindest
was, was in diesem Bereich fällt.
Wo ich gar keinen Bock drauf hätte, ist zum Beispiel
an unserer Java-Anwendung großartig mit
zu entwickeln.
Unseren Java-Anwendung.
Aber
ja, gut.
Ich hab mal 2007
habe ich Fach-Informatiker-System-
Integration gelernt. Und seitdem hat sich
ich meine, das ist 15 Jahre her. Seitdem
hat sich die IT-Welt schon eine ganze
Runde
weiter gedreht.
Mit Nagios.
Nagios war eines meiner ersten Dinger, wo ich mich
richtig gut auskanne. Nagios interessiert heute kein
Sau mehr.
Wobei ich persönlich
immer noch eine
weiche Stelle,
oder ein Herz für Nagios habe.
Ich mag Nagios immer noch, aber
ich glaube keiner macht heute neue Nagios-
Installationen mehr.
Richtig Boomer, ja.
Was man heute macht, das kommt drauf an, was man
übermachen will. Also Prometheus ist heute äußerst
angesagt.
Elk, also Elasticsearch.
Kibana ist relativ angesagt.
Subbix für so eine All-in-One-Geschichte
ist angesagt. Dann gibt es noch jede Menge
Cloud-Services,
sowas wie Data,
Data-Doc oder sowas.
Da gibt es so viele, da kann ich mir
alles die Hälfte, kann ich mir davon gar nicht
bemerken. Dann hast du im Netzwerk-Bereich,
im Netzwerk-Bereich hast du dann eher solche
Sachen wie
Libre-NMS
und solche Dinger, wo du dann über
SNMP-Monitors, es kommt auf den
Einsatzbereich an.
Subbix ist eine wunderbare
All-in-One-Lösung, finde ich.
Auch wenn die Subbix-Config halt
abfuck ist.
Dafür ist das schöne, aber als habe ich
die alles, die können sogar Prometheus-Sachen
importieren mittlerweile und abfragen.
Ohne, dass man
Prometheus laufen haben muss und sowas.
Echt?
Lul.
Ja.
Ich auch.
Ich habe sogar einen eigenen Prometheus-Exporter für
meine Heizung programmiert, haben wir im Stream
gemacht, falls ihr euch noch dran erinnern könnt.
Heizungsdaten über Prometheus
exportieren.
Ich habe euch das Dashboard schon eine Weile nicht mehr gezeigt.
Also Prometheus ist mit
eines der beliebtesten Dinger
heute. Wobei man halt sagen muss,
und das kann man glaube ich nicht oft genug sagen,
es gibt unterschiedlich sinnvolle Tools
für unterschiedliche Einsatzzwecke. Also
Prometheus kann zwar prinzipiell
alles, aber gerade so für dieses
klassische wie Monitoren von außen
und gucken, ob etwas up oder down ist. Wir gucken, ob
ein Port hochgefahren ist oder runtergefahren
ist und sowas. Das kannst du mit dem
Prometheus machen. Du kannst ja auch
irgendwelche Blackbox-Exporter
Label-Rewrite-Magic-Sachen
überlegen und so. Das geht,
aber du merkst, dass Prometheus
eigentlich nicht dafür gedacht ist. Oder
ursprünglich nicht dafür erfunden wurde.
Für so klassisches, mach einen Ping, guck
ob der Host up oder down ist. Prometheus
hat die Stärken eindeutig
darin, Metriken
über eigene Anwendungen zu sammeln. Oder sagen wir mal,
Metriken zu sammeln dort, wo Prometheus
native supported wird. Sei es
jetzt eine Anwendung, die selbst quasi
Prometheus Daten anbietet oder eine eigene
Anwendung, die ich hab in der eigenen
Jahrphase, die ich hab, was auch immer Anwendung, die
interne Sachen
quasi als Prometheus-Metrik exportiert.
Dann weiß ich zum Beispiel, wie oft läuft
mein Garbage-Collector? Hab ich irgendwelche
Memory Leaks? Wie viele Threads brauche ich?
Wie viele Threads in meinem Threadpool
stauen sich und sowas? So interne
Anwendungsmetriken, dafür ist
Prometheus richtig gut und da gibt's, finde ich, auch
nicht viel besseres.
Für sie ist diese klassische Sache, ist der Service
hoch, ist der Service da, läuft
der Port, kommt bei einem HTTP-Request
das Richtige zurück. Und dieses klassische
wir monitoren von
außen was,
finde ich, ist Prometheus machbar, aber nicht
so schön.
Ja.
Wenn dein
Zeug auf Kubernetes läuft,
vielleicht, aber es gibt ja
durchaus auch genug klassische
Infrastruktur und
man muss ja irgendwie auch seinen
Kubernetes-Cluster monitorn.
Und sei es nur auf
Firmware-Versionen von den Management-Interfaces,
ob die Netzwerkkarten irgendwelche
Fehler schmeißen oder sonst was.
Und irgendwann kommt man dann auf die glorreiche
Idee, vielleicht muss man seinen Monitor
auch noch monitoren, man kann das ja beliebig weit
spinnen.
Die Sache ist die, was ich sagen will,
du hast durchaus sinnvolle
Tools für
unterschiedliche Anwendungsbereiche.
Du musst Netzwerkswitches zum Beispiel monitorn,
da kommst du mit einem Kubernetes-Dashboard nicht
sonderlich weiter und du kommst
mit irgendwelchen Prometheus-Exportern
auch nicht sonderlich weiter.
Wenn du Netzwerkswitches monitorn willst, klar,
du kannst dir irgendeinen SNMP-Exporter nehmen,
der auf einer Kiste läuft, neben dem
Switch, der den Switch-Abfragen dann wieder bereit
stellt. Aber dort ist es beispielsweise
viel einfacher, du hast einen Zapix oder
ein Libre-NMS oder irgendwas, was
per SNMP direkt den Switch abfragt.
Ja, wir haben mehrere
Cluster und das Witzige ist, bei
unserem Kubernetes-Zeug,
das ist mittlerweile so krasser Wildwuchs,
an Namespaces
und hast du nicht gesehen, dass
keiner mehr eigentlich genau weiß, wer für was
zuständig ist, geschweige denn
irgendjemand den Überblick hat, wenn was
kaputt geht.
Also Kubernetes bei mir auf der Arbeit
ist so ein typischer Fall von,
man hat eigentlich keine Ahnung, was man da genau macht,
fängt aber schon mal an
und dann geht's live. Und dann
hat immer noch keiner eine Ahnung davon, was man eigentlich macht,
aber dann ist es live und man muss es weiter betreiben.
Historisch gewachsen, genau.
Tja.
Also, wie gesagt, es gibt verschiedene
Monitoring-Systeme und die sind in unterschiedlichen
Anwendungsfällen unterschiedlich sinnvoll.
Man kann alles mit Prometheus
irgendwie abfackeln, das funktioniert,
weil es für alles mögliche Exporter gibt,
aber halt nicht so schön und manchmal auch sehr
umständlich und dann auch nicht so intuitiv.
Und vielleicht auch manche sagen gar nicht richtig.
Also so klassische Sachen wie Zabbix
oder auch Nagios, die haben durchaus ihre
Daseinsberechtigung.
Ich finde, man sollte halt nicht sagen,
hey, dieses eine Tool ist jetzt
im Hype und das ist das Beste für alles.
Was ist es meistens nicht? Man muss sich immer die besten
Tools raussuchen für das, was man machen will.
Insofern der Aufwand
ist rechtfertig. Wenn ich jetzt
im Prinzip mit meiner Prometheus-
Geschichte in 99% der Fälle zufrieden bin,
jetzt aber vielleicht
noch 3 Server zusätzlich
überwachen will, ob DNS läuft oder
sonst was, dann brauche ich natürlich nichts extra.
Na ja, so, gucken wir mal weiter.
Was, was, gucken wir uns mal sehen.
Achso, wir waren immer noch bei CSS.
Ja, so stelle ich mir das vor, nachdem ich
eben gesehen habe.
Ich habe auch mal
in einem Stream important verwendet
bei CSS. Da hat jemand im Chat geschrieben
Max, ich verlängere den Sub nicht.
Also anscheinend ist important nahe an
Restaurant für manche Leute.
Übrigens, diese
Namen
der Colors
in HTML, die haben teilweise
richtig interessante
Hintergründe. Zum Beispiel
eine Color ist
nach der Tochter eines,
weiß ich gar nicht, Mozilla
Entwicklers oder so, benannt,
die gestorben
ist und die haben nach ihr dann quasi eine
HTML-Farbe benannt
und sowas. Also wenn man
sich fragt, warum diese Dinger manchmal
so random wirre Namen haben,
die haben oftmals eine
Hintergrund.
E-React-Circuits
Okay, er hat mich schon verloren, ich habe
keine Ahnung, was bin ich sehend,
was ist das?
Moment, das ist plain CSS?
Das ist plain CSS, habe ich auch nie
gesehen.
But we're still dealing with plain CSS
here and one thing it lacks is programmatic
features like loops, functions,
mixins and things like that. The classic
way to make CSS better is to use a
preprocessor, which allows you to write a
different syntax like Sass, less
or stylus, then use a compiler
to convert that code back into plain
CSS. Also wenn du für deinen CSS
schon einen Compiler brauchst, dann ist vorbei.
Wobei wir haben im Stream auch mal
ein bisschen Sass gebastelt, ich fand das
ziemlich coole Sache. Das fand ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Ja, das fand ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Ja, fand ich jetzt schlecht.
Moment, das ist ja nicht alles.
Die coolen Leute heutzutage machen
noch Rust to WebAssembly dabei,
weil die coolen Leute die machen
selbstverständlich Rust, weil Rust machen
halt die coolen Leute und WebAssembly
machen auch die coolen Leute. Das ist doppelt cool
wenn du Rust WebAssembly machst.
Rust Stream, boah, ich weiß nicht, ob wir uns
das wirklich antun wollen. Ich habe ja früher
schon als das ganz neu war ein bisschen
Rust gemacht, also komplett planlos
bin ich nicht was Rust angeht, aber
Rust ist halt wirklich richtige
high IQ only Sprache.
Also CSS in JavaScript ist mir
suspekt. Ja, das mag ich, das mag ich.
Moment, es gibt einen zweiten, gibt es einen Tailwind
Fork oder was? Was ist Windy CSS? Tailwind
kenne ich. Warum gibt es in diesem ganzen
Frontend Ökosystem alle paar Wochen
irgendwas Neues? Das ist so, das ist so
ätzend teilweise. Okay, das muss ich jetzt mal
nachgucken. Was ist das? Windy CSS.
Browser ist sus, ja.
Windy CSS, next generation utility first
CSS Framework. Okay, warum sollte ich das
jetzt verwenden anstatt Tailwind? Vor allem
was ist denn das Problem an Tailwind
eigentlich? Was ondemandet, was? Okay, ich
verstehe schon den Satz überhaupt nicht.
Okay, if you are already familiar with
Tailwind CSS, think about Windy CSS
as an ondemanded alternative, eine
Aufverfügbarkeit, verfügbare.
Okay, okay, why Windy CSS? Okay, it's
fully compatible with Tailwind 2.0.
Okay, when my project become larger
and dozens of components. Ja, aber das
Problem hat man bei Tailwind doch gar
nicht mehr. Tailwind hat doch mittlerweile
auch ihre komische Aufsplitlogik im
Dev-Modus, das Problem gibt es doch gar
nicht mehr. Also im Prinzip wurde das
erstellt zu einer Zeit, als es da
Probleme mit gab, aber die Probleme gibt
es überhaupt nicht mehr, alles klar. Und
why exactly, also warum sollte ich jetzt
egal, ich hinterfrage Frontend Zeug
einfach nicht weiter, wir gucken jetzt
das Video fertig. Da drehst du
durch, also ganz ehrlich, Browser
Frontend Kram ist so ein Ding. Wenn du,
also mal angenommen, du bist der richtig
mega krasse Frontend Def und hast von
allem Ahnung und bist der Oberchecker
schlechthin, so, und keine Ahnung, du
bekommst Corona und musst eine Woche
ins Krankenhaus ohne Rechner, du kommst
wieder und du darfst deine Anwendung
neu schreiben, weil alle hippen
Frameworks jetzt andere sind. Eine Woche
reicht da schon, das ist voll und ganz
ausreichend. Okay, es ist natürlich
weit zu übertrieben, mittlerweile ist es
gerade was große Frameworks angeht,
nicht mehr ganz so wild. Zu den letzten
drei, vier Jahre, es ist Angular, es ist
React und es ist Vue.js und da ändert
sich auch nicht so viel dran. Es gibt
links und rechts immer mal wieder neue
Sachen, sowas wie Svelte oder was weiß
ich, was hat letztens irgendjemand
empfohlen im Chat? Solid habe ich noch
nie gehört, also es gibt immer mal wieder
die ein oder andere Sachen, aber die
großen Dinge sind React, Vue, Angular.
Fertig.
Das beschreibt es zu gut. Das habe ich
auf das Video, das gucken wir uns danach
an. Das da, ja, das wurde mir auch
empfohlen vorhand.
Wir gucken jetzt aber das Video erstmal
fertig.
Ja, das mag ich. Das mag ich.
Das mag ich.
Also Tailwind ist mir
lieber als CSS
selbst basteln, weil
was ich bei Tailwind mag, ist, dass die
gut zueinander passenden Farben standardmäßig
auch für alles Mögliche drin haben,
weil ich bin ein absoluter Design Noob,
was das angeht.
Ja, da kann man sich jetzt drüber
streiten, was besser ist. Das finde ich
ist ein guter Punkt. Er schreibt hier
ehrlich gesagt, habe ich es lieber, wenn
ein Fork mit neuen Features entsteht, statt
das einzelne Paket immer mehr neue
Features aufkleben wird, wie die. Also
ich finde, das beste Prinzip ist
tatsächlich so, wie das Vue.js macht.
Man kann sich jetzt über das Upgrade von
zwei auf drei streiten. Die haben ein paar
offizielle supportete Pakete für
die Basic Funktion.
Und
das Problem ist, wenn du
quasi alles als externe
Libraries hast, die nicht von dem Hauptprojekt
sind, du weißt nicht, ob die
morgen eingestellt werden oder du weißt
nicht, ob der Typ morgen noch Bock
hat oder du weißt nicht,
wann es irgendwelche Dependencies kaputt
macht oder was auch immer. Also
ich finde, es hat durchaus seinen Vorteil,
wenn es
die wichtigsten Funktionen
und vielleicht auch darüber hinaus
von offizieller Seite gibt.
Ich meine,
React ist wohl das
krasseste Beispiel in der Richtung.
Die können standardmäßig nichts und es gibt
für React 30 Milliarden Libraries.
Wo du aber morgen nicht weißt, ob das
noch angesagt ist, ob das noch
supportet ist oder sonst was. Dann hast du das
Negativbeispiel, das für Angular. Die machen
alles in einem riesen Package.
Die machen alles in einem riesen Package.
Und du hast Vue.js. Die haben
das wichtigste in Vue
drinne, haben aber noch zusätzliche
offizielle Packages,
wie zum Beispiel ihren CraftQL Client
oder ihr State Management Zeug,
als Zusatzpackages, die auch
offiziell sind und
morgen nicht verschwinden, aber die nicht
Bestandteile sind des normalen
Packages. Das finde ich ist so die beste
Kombination
aus der Geschichte.
Ihr habt übrigens
immer noch nicht fertig geguckt, das Video.
Ich brauche wieder ewig für ein
5-Minuten-Video.
Ich mag das.
Ich mag Tailwind.
Für mich ist das genau richtig.
Das macht ja nichts.
Ganz ehrlich,
seitdem ich angefangen habe mich ein bisschen
mehr mit so Frontend-Sachen
zu beschäftigen.
Ich finde es gar nicht so schlecht,
wenn man die Sachen mal
selber baut, weil es ist ja nicht
so, als bräuchtest du bei einer normalen
Web-Anwendung
die 500 Komponenten, die beispielsweise
Beautify hat oder so.
Du brauchst da
3-4 zusätzliche
Dinge und gut ist.
Und viele Sachen sind gar nicht
so schwierig zu bauen.
Beispielsweise einen Input mit
Autocomplete oder sowas.
Das ist kein Hextenwerk.
Das haben wir sogar hier letztens im Stream gemacht.
Das ist gar nicht so
schwierig.
Also so ein riesen Vorteil versus
ein fertiges Ding
zu verwenden,
weiß ich in dem Fall gar nicht.
Zumal da halt 30 Milliarden Sachen drin sind,
wo du dich erst mit beschäftigen musst und im Endeffekt,
die du auch gar nicht brauchst.
Also ich glaube, das Wichtigste,
was jeder der Frontend macht,
tun kann ist,
sich ein bisschen damit zu beschäftigen,
wie man dafür sorgt, dass Webseiten ganz gut aussehen.
Da tue ich mir ja auch schwer.
Ich habe Schwierigkeiten,
die passende Farbauswahl zu nehmen.
immer noch ordentlich,
wie ich
Grid ordentlich bediene, wie ich Flex
ordentlich bediene und sowas.
Aber das ist glaube ich das Beste, was man machen kann,
als alles fertige Komponenten zu verwenden,
weil im Endeffekt
lernst du halt
damit, wie es funktioniert
und baust dir dann
deine drei Komponenten selbst, die du brauchst.
Dann musst du nicht 50 Libraries
ausprobieren, bis du die eine Library
gefunden hast, die das kann,
was du willst, mit diesem einen
zusätzlichen Feature, sondern baust halt
ein Inputfeld zu einem Autocomplete
um selbst und da hast du genau das, was du brauchst.
Und selbst Keyboard-Navigation
in einem Inputfeld zu bauen,
ist jetzt kein Hexenwerk.
Das geht, das ist jetzt nicht so wild.
Egal.
Mit Bootstrap hat alles angefangen.
Bootstrap, es gab mal eine
Zeit lang
es gab mal eine Zeit lang
diesen Trend, dass jede Webseite ausgesehen
hat wie Bootstrap. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das noch
kennt, da wusstest du gleich schon, du gehst
auf irgendeine Startup-Seite oder du gehst auf
irgendeine neue hippe XY-
Service-Seite. Es war
Bootstrap. Mittlerweile ist
Bootstrap aber out. Mittlerweile
ist das abgelöst
durch Material-Design und ich muss euch ganz
ehrlich sagen,
ähm, ich
mag Material-Design nicht.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass das, dass das
leicht aussieht,
ich mag's aber nicht.
Zumal Material-Design das
neue Bootstrap ist.
Jeder, jedes hat irgendwie
alles und jedes hat irgendwie Material-Design.
Also, ich finde den aktuellen Trend
tatsächlich ganz gut,
es möglichst minimalistisch zu machen
und irgendwie
ein bisschen mit
sozusagen Wiedererkennungs-
Was heißt Wiedererkennungs-
Das ist das falsche Wort. Minimalistisch
und auf die, auf
ein bisschen mehr auf den Inhalt fokussiert
wieder.
Und Animationen nur an Stellen verwendet,
wo es sinnvoll ist und sowas.
Oder auch, ähm,
ja, wie soll ich sagen,
der aktuelle Trend Web-Design-Technik
ist ja möglichst minimalistisch und wieder
mehr Fokus auf den Inhalt legen
der Web-Seite anstatt
auch Spielereien.
Das sieht man ja zum Beispiel daran, dass diese
ganzen, guckt euch ihre
nächstbeliebige Start-Up-Seite an,
die haben alle den gleichen
Style von
hier Produkt XY,
hier Getting Started,
hier Video oder sowas in der
Richtung.
Und wahrscheinlich weil es funktioniert und ich finde
gar nicht schlecht.
Ja, Bootstrap, mit Bootstrap bin ich nie
richtig warm geworden.
Also mein Geldautomat hat auch, ja,
also das ist mir auch letztens aufgefallen bei der
Sparkasse, der Geldautomat
hat jetzt nicht nur Animationen,
der Geldautomat hat jetzt auch Werbung,
die du erstmal wegklicken musst, wenn
du Geld abheben willst.
Was zum Teufel ist Mantine schon
wieder?
Ist das schon wieder was
Neues?
Ich kriege Anfälle Frontend,
Alter.
Ah, React-Komponents-Library.
Okay,
React-Gedöns.
Okay, das ist nur React-Zeug von hier.
Doch, also mein Sparkassenautomat
hat Werbung drauf für die Sparkasse.
Ja, okay, wir sollen seinen Kurs kaufen, alles klar.
Okay, wollen wir uns doch das Interview mit dem
JavaScript-Developer hinterher angucken?
Das hat mir jetzt der Chat schon ein paar Mal gepostet
und nachdem YouTube mir das heute Morgen
empfohlen hat, mache ich das jetzt mal an.
Was? Nur eine?
Achso.
Dieses Jahr, Moment, Moment.
Dieses Jahr ist das Jahr des
Linux-Desktops sind für uns doch einig.
Ja, Elektron.
Alles klar.
Oh Gott, CoffeeScript gab's ja auch noch.
Das ist ja wieder komplett verdrängt.
Geil, ich spiele ja Libraries.
Wait, war das ein Witzung?
Jetzt oder ernst gemeint? Gibt es wirklich einen jQuery-Fog, der jQuery heißt? Ich traue den alles zu.
Natürlich ist Null ein Objekt, aber Objekte können Null sein, also können sie technisch kein Objekt sein, unless sie ein Objekt sind, oder?
Natürlich ist Null ein Objekt, ja. Es ist ein bisschen hackig, aber JavaScript ist durch Design. Ist es einfach zu lernen?
Habt ihr JavaScript probiert? Wahrscheinlich werden wir ein bisschen hackig. Habt ihr JavaScript vorher genutzt? Ich empfehle es nicht. Ich mag nicht unsere Toolchain.
Dokumentierung? Und ein weiterer Vorteil ist, dass es gratis ist. So war es mit Java, bevor es von Oracle gekauft wurde.
Wir bereiten uns an, Modules von NPM zu installieren. Dann kompilen wir sie in TypeScript, dann benutzen wir einen Transpiler, den Bubble, um es in ES5 zu transpilen, mit System.js zu laden, File für Bankruptcy zu machen, es mit Webpack zu verbinden, es in einem Framework wie React zu benutzen und das Statement durch Redux oder Flux, Flummox oder Flexible oder Recoil oder was auch immer zu benutzen, JS.
Und voilà. All of this just to avoid using jQuery or in our case jjQuery. But that will be probably less performant as most of the things. This isn't our production code. It will be tomorrow though. Probably gonna get fired again.
I mean there is really no alternative to JavaScript right now. De facto. No one really knows what the value is until we get an error. I love it. Well try writing anything without JavaScript nowadays. JavaScript. I love it. No, I don't recommend it.
Ja, da ist schon was dran. Ja, da ist schon was dran. Ja, da ist schon was dran. Logik sucht man an vielen Stellen und in JavaScript tatsächlich vergebens.
Sind wir wach Leute? Noch nicht oder? Noch nicht wach. Oder sind wir schon wach, ich weiß nicht. Also nachdem ich jetzt die ganze Zeit schon ein bisschen husten muss, bin ich ernsthaft am Überlegen ob ich nicht den Stream jetzt ausmache, dass ich nicht, dass es nicht mit dem Hals schlimmer wird wieder.
JQuery wird noch immer sehr oft verwendet. Ja klar. Weil es in vielen alten Webseiten drin ist und bei irgendwelchen Sachen als Dependencies auch noch mit. Ich mein man darf nicht vergessen, dass bis glaube ich.NET 3 das Standard ASP.NET Core Web Template jQuery mit als Dependency hatte. Mitgebracht hat.
Gar nicht so lange her.
Der SMS Pummel Deutschland 2000. Ja, da war ich live dabei.
SMS. Im Prinzip gab es zwei Sachen. Es gab drei Sachen, die man mit dem Handy gemacht hat. Das erste ist Snake spielen. Zweitens SMS schicken und das dritte ist ab und zu mal telefonieren. Kennt noch jemand WAP?
Hat man hier mal eine WAP Webseite aufgemacht? Also ich weiß, das ist Boomer Technologie. Das kennt man heutzutage nicht mehr, aber auch ganz großer Paints Champ.
Alles Legacy Technologie, genauso wie Videotext. Und das war teuer damals, Leute. Wenn ihr da aus Versehen mal den Browser aufgemacht habt. Da wart ihr arm danach.
Was kennt einer noch DOT? DOT, DOT, DOT minus WIN? Nein, das kenne ich nicht.
Battlefield 3 ist für mich bestimmt. Da war die Prepaid Karte leer nach dem WAP. Ja, das stimmt. Das war vorbei. Leute, ich gehe jetzt auf und dann gehe ich was futtern, weil ich habe keinen Bock, dass das Halstechnik wieder schlimmer wird.
Wir sehen uns. Bis denn. War ein bisschen kürzer. Vielleicht machen wir nachher noch ein bisschen Progas. Mal gucken. Bis denn. See you.